From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
I'm good.
Okay.
We're rolling.
Okay. So today is Saturday, April 13th, where Malibu, California, and this is David Cline on behalf of the Southern Oral History Program.
And the Smithsonian Institutes National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And today I will be the interviewer.
I'm with John Bishop, the videographer, and Willie Leventhal.
And Willie wanted to thank you very much for being part of our project.
You know, it's a good story.
The whole of this, the Pacific Ocean is behind this, well, well.
It's a great honor.
And I think that, you know, this was a key part of American history and world history.
And there are so many lessons for the world to know about how you try and change things without violence.
And so I'm more than happy to be a part of this.
Thank you so much.
So, Will, I wanted, if I could ask you to start just by telling us about where you grew up and how you grew up and how you may have seen some of the lessons that you learned early on playing out in the work that you chose.
Born in New York in 46, but my dad had just gotten back from World War II.
He had a very good chiropractic practice in Saginaw, Michigan when he went in the war.
My mother, who was a teacher and later a college professor at USC, a special ed, went back and lived with her family in Staten Island.
And when my dad got out, I had to sort of start over again, you know, after a couple years away for service.
And, you know, that was when the migration was happening to California.
And apparently he talked to some people in Michigan and they said, yeah, there's a lot of opportunity out there.
Still being in the service, he could fly free out to California and Bernard, Dr. Bernard Leventhal' name.
They were both my parents, remember, as an NAACP at different times.
I don't know at that time, but I know that Hubert Humphrey was his big hero from 1948.
In fact, when I worked for George McGovern, took here in 1972 and we got the nomination over Hubert Humphrey.
It took many decades for my father to forgive me for working against Hubert Humphrey, who was his hero of his generation as many like Jackie Robinson, Amart, Luther King, and John Kennedy, for my generation.
So we moved to New York to California. When I was two, we didn't have much to start with out here.
So we lived in Ramona Gardens, which was a federal housing project, probably about 1948.
My mother worked in the campaign of the first Hispanic councilman and then later congressmen.
But I'm blanking on his name. The federal building is named for him downtown. I'll think of it later.
Roybal, Edward R. Roybal. Since we become friends with somebody at Cal State LA, did a book about Edward R. Roybal.
My sister had talked to Edward R. Roybal before he died. His daughter, Lucille Roybal-Allard, has his seat.
He remembered my mother. My mother was an activist.
And my grandfather had been the assistant superintendent of New York City Schools, Morris Segal, and had handled all the veterans retreating and all the vocational education after World War II.
So I come from a family of educators on my mom's side. My dad were also immigrants. His father and mother were immigrants as my grandparents on both sides.
And they had shoe stores. They had shoe stores. And then the typical next generation became a college educated.
My dad was the only one of his generation to be college educated.
So we lived in the projects for a couple of years. And I think that shaped me in the sense I saw pictures in the book you have of Hispanic kids, Asian kids, black kids, all living in that.
In fact, the picture from the LA weekly, I could have had that picture taken anywhere when they chose me as a person of the year after I went to the White House for the Civil Rights Concert.
And I particularly went back to Murchison Street Elementary School, which is right up the street from the projects.
When my brother and sister went and I substitute taught when I worked in LA here, Steve for five years. And so those are my roots East LA, East Los.
So I'm culturally, I think mostly Jewish, but a good bit Hispanic and black, particularly the food for both of those cultures.
But anyway, so we then moved to North Hollywood. My dad first built in some of his veterans' buddies from the Jewish War veterans.
They built a little front to the house we bought. And that was his waiting room. And he used to do his adjustments in the living room.
And then he made a little more success in him and one guy built about an eight room office in front of our house.
My parents then divorced. And I moved with my mom. She was a special ed teacher in the public schools and like the county public special ed program better than the city.
And so we ended up in the first in Westchester and then in the South Bay area. And I think Westchester was a very key event in my life.
Beyond my family's commitment to quote unquote liberal of that day, which was a very close bond between Jews and blacks and the NAACP Legal Defense Fund with Jack Greenberg and others worked with Thurgood Marshall.
And my grandfather, as I said in an article, I had donated money to the defense of the Scottsboro Boys. The parents were part of the NAACP, you know, as far as membership.
My father, as I said, loved you were done free. But when I was a little baseball player at age 10, most of the kids were Catholic. And they never directed the word kike to me personally, but they used it as a kind of a slang negative word you kike you this.
I'm going to do you down that that was also very prevalent in South Bay. Only three Jewish families in my high school. Again, never directed at me and me really not knowing what to make of it, but very painful to a child.
Because of course as a child, you want to fit in, you want to you don't want people. And of course I didn't understand why they would even say that about my religion.
Because I like my parents and the people I met at Temple, they didn't do anything wrong that I knew of. And of course at that time within the Catholic Church, there was the, which later changed and it's a whole different day in the Catholic Church in terms of relations with Israel and Judaism.
And Judaism, in those days, there was the Christ killer that was at that particular for a certain time. So came out and then the next thing that happened, which is tremendously connected to the word kike, was the Jackie Robinson movie, Jackie Robinson story, which I saw at age five.
And here on the screen, there were two things that I related to, baseball, which I love, still love. And racial prejudice or prejudice towards somebody and mistreatment of somebody more verbally with Robinson in that movie than otherwise.
And in the Jack Robinson movie, which came out this weekend, there was a great scene with Harrison Ford, Willie Terrells, the Jack Robinson actor. I was just there and there's a little white boy who was imitating you. And I talked to Andrew Young about the movie and Andy said, the movie was great best civil rights move I've ever saw. And he said, I thought of you when I saw the movie thinking of me.
And he may have thought, I've been trying to get Jackie's teammates involved with the civil rights game. I was one that got Andrew Young involved through my RBI involvement went with him to Cincinnati when he gave the address there at the civil rights game in 2009 or 10.
And I didn't identify with Jackie as a ball player. First of all, he was such he was probably the best athlete in the country for many years, maybe of all time. Him and Jim Thorpe were close, but Jackie was unbelievable athlete.
(Jackie Robinson) projected to be in the 1940 Olympics like it was a brother Mac, but they had no Olympics that year. Would I identified with Jackie Robinson? I always tried to describe it as, whoa, because by that time Willie Willie Mays around blacks or plan. You don't hear of any. I didn't know anything about this. I was 10 years old. I just knew the blacks were in the big leagues. They were my heroes somewhere on Brooklyn Dodgers. That's all I knew. And I remember the way I described it as in my 10 year old mind, it was my the grownups didn't tell me about this.
They didn't tell me about any of this. The blacks and whites couldn't play baseball. I want to find out more about this. I want to find out about this. They really picked my my curiosity. And I wanted to be like Jackie Robinson not as a player because I didn't think that much at that time when I eventually learned about Jackie Robinson. I knew I wasn't going to be Jackie Robinson.
And no one else was going to be Jackie Robinson by the way either, but I couldn't run fast and Jackie could certainly run fast. But he was a healer. What Jackie did, what impressed me in that film was he challenged the people that were saying mean things and hurting people's feelings. And he made it better. And he helped people whose feelings were hurt. And his feelings were hurt, but he was tough enough strong enough courageous enough dedicated enough, you know, an exceptional enough athlete to over the world.
And that was what fascinated me. And that's what he became a hero for. Not that he could play baseball, that he could be that he could heal this terrible hurt that I felt not to the extent that he felt or that African Americans felt, but it was still a pain. It was still a confusion to me.
My mother was smart enough when I was I didn't get by Mitzett mainly because I wanted to play baseball on Saturday when the religious school was all my friends were playing baseball. And I don't want to take that much time out to go to the religious school because I've been Mr. Many Games with my mom let me get away with after the divorce.
My dad didn't care. He was a secular teacher. He didn't go after World War II. He said, you know, I don't believe in God after all, you know, that he was a secular teacher to identify with Israel.
My mother wanted me to have a Jewish education. My grandfather, Seagull, really wanted me to have one. When I got 15, she said, you must be confirmed. And I fought it, but she forced me, one of the first things she ever forced me to do. And then I embraced it. All the other Jewish kids were just getting done with it. They were couldn't wait to get done. And I discovered it. And one of my buddies in the confirmation class was a guy named Mike Vogel turned out to be first to be a student.
Turned out to be first team All City in football and baseball at Westchester High where I would have gone had I not moved.
Played us. Played was second team All American at Northridge football full back. I played baseball. I don't know if he was All America. And then played some pro football.
Another one of the non-Woodie Allen-esque Jews who were athletes in strong and macho. And I love Woody Allen for his talent.
Not for his representation of the Jewish male because some of us are not nebish little wimps, no disrespect to Woody Allen. But we like to think of ourselves as very good athletes who competed, whose role models were Hank Greenberg, Sandy Koufax, Al Rosen, who was a boxer.
And I had a chance to meet Al Rosen and Sandy Koufax and interview Sandy Koufax. And spend some time with Al Rosen when he was out with Ted Williams in Iowa.
You know the Jewish community needs to recognize there's a stream that runs from Hank and Al and Sandy through Mike Vogel, who was much better than me.
But I was good enough to be on one of the best teams in the state. And lots of Jews are that good. Mike's safe for UCLA and his three sons who were professional athletes.
I just name a few. And that's my challenge to my own culture. When Snick said go work in your own community, I got a lot of work to do in the Jewish community.
Still, then and now. That more now. So you asked about my early years. But the early years were influenced by my family, by the divorce coming from a broken home with Jackie Robinson also didn't have a fall.
I mean, there was a lot of things that I could identify with Jackie Robinson. And then I went up to UCLA. And the other big influence that that early part of my life was John Kennedy.
He was so charismatic. He was a good looking PT-109. He was a World War II hero. I mean, you couldn't have been much more heroic for me at that age than torn somebody through the water and these things. He was also very funny.
He gave such a great speech. We're coming up to the anniversary in June. The night before Medgar Evers was killed about the issue being as old as the scriptures and as current as our Constitution.
And you know Eisenhower was a grandfather figure to my generation. Kennedy was the new frontier. And also, of course, they asked not what your country can do for you, but what you can do for your country. That resonated. I was.
Had I not gone south, I would have been attracted towards the Peace Corps, but I went. Dr. King found me before the Peace Corps found me. But I was very, you know, that was a great thing that for my generation in terms of idealism.
So those were really, and then that was very primed. And then of course, when I was 12, Brooklyn Dodgers came out. They had three Jews on the team. They had Sandy Koufax, Norm Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry + Norm Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry and Norm Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry. And what a great deal. By 59, Sandy was just coming into his own. And Norm Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry + Norm Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry + Norm Sherry + Larry Sherry was the World Series MVP.
One two games, save two games. So as a Jewish kid, that was thrilling. And I actually got to work out with Brooklyn Dodgers three times when I was 13 and 14.
At the Colosseum on the floor, Pete Reiser kind of adopted me. And Gil Hodges as well gets sitting the bench with him. So that was pretty neat.
So I had a lot of great things with my childhood. And then Dr. King came to UCLA when I was 18 and asked for volunteers.
And now the summer community organization and political education project, which was known as scope, SCOPE project, and made the National Nelson at UCLA.
I'm quite sure because of Ralph Bunche and Jackie Robinson, each of whom had been on the front lines with him every year from 60 through 65.
One or the other.
How aware of the civil rights movement or King were you before he came to UCLA?
Actually, my, and I'm, I'm, this is 65.
Yeah, I'm going to name drop because Harris Wofford and I are good friends along with Andy. I'm those are my two big, big name friends of mine.
Some, but wonderful men. And Harris and I, Harris was just in Birmingham with Almopile and Diane McWhorter. And, and he mentioned, I said, well, I'm maybe I'll be back in DC, the anniversary of the March in Washington.
And he said, were you there? And I said, well, no, I wasn't yet 17. I was getting ready for high school football and I had my own column in the Valley News and Greensheet.
I was only kid that had his own column and covered B football. And then when I got to play varsity, they sent her her crop.
And I remember the name photographer over with the orders, only take pictures of Willie Leventhal. And of course, he took six pictures. All of me in one was in the paper the next day.
So I was very happy. The little bit I got to play, at least I got in the paper.
So, we went to the City Finals, which was on TV and I was coaching third bass instead of playing, which was extremely disappointing.
But we were in the City Finals and that was for those days, it was a big deal. There was no divisions. It was one tournament, one out of all the City of LA and two teams made it.
And in Birmingham, we had beat him five times in a row and they beat us. And my teammates never kind of forgave themselves for losing that game.
So those influences were going on. And I was what I said about Tahris. I was aware of the March in Washington, but I was in California, I was 16.
I was trying to get some playing time in football. I was little and not very big. I was in a new school. I just been there three quarters of my junior year, going in my senior year.
But I knew what was going on. And also the three guys that were killed in Mississippi to a re-Jewish that same summer, or the summer before, next summer, when I was a senior, my senior summer, that had a big impact on me.
The first time I really remember, as I told Harris, and the March in Washington, Jackie Robinson was far more the influence of my life than Martin Luther King.
Twenty months later, Dr. King came and wanted to ask for volunteers. But I remember very clearly being aware enough, Dr. King went into Selma January 1st at the request of many of the educators. Some of the snake people will say that they did all the work and Dr. King came and took the credit.
There was a group of educators and town leaders. And the way Andy and Hosea Williams tell about it, snicked a great work in Selma. But they were beaten down. The repression was terrible. The violence was terrible.
And unfortunately, the media didn't cover enough. The Justice Department didn't do enough. And they suffered a lot of losses as they had in Mississippi.
But the fact was, they were being beaten down. And we didn't need the media there. And those leaders in the town, and they were very easy to research and find out (Mrs. Amelia) Boynton was certainly one of them.
And there were some others in the school system. Requested Dr. King and SCLC came in. And I remember the article in the paper, January 2nd, I remember, so, well, I had a girlfriend up in Big Sur that I was trying to commute back and forth from UCLA, which was quite difficult.
But her father was a Navy veteran. He was in the hospital. He had a drinking problem. And he was critical of Dr. King. And he was trying to tell me, well, the service that didn't work and the black need grows for this and that. And I said, you know what? This is about voting.
I said, I don't care what you're talking about. This is a democracy. They're trying to register to vote. You're not going to persuade me that he's doing something wrong.
So I had that conversation with my girlfriend, stepfather. And I mean, I have noticed it in the paper anyway. And I think I was, again, the 60 killings in 64 and Freedom Summer. But that was my first time I can personally now remember knowing what Martin Luther King was doing.
It was news when he went into Selma. And then I followed that. Of course, it was big news. And it was the the Selma-to-Montgomery marches, you know, the Selma-to-Montgomery marches. I think it was the Selma-to-Montgomery marches.
There was the Selma-to-Montgomery marches. They call it the Selma-to-Montgomery marches. And you know, little did I know that Hosea Williams would become one of my dearest, dearest closest friends. I would have, at this point, the only book about him.
He's got a manuscript that he flew me down for to work on him. And he would, we were, we're going to go to Savannah. We're going to go down to out of Pogless. Then we'd be in the office and a poor person would come. And he didn't interrupt our work and go counsel the poor person.
And which is a wonderful thing about him because he had the poor people's church of love. Martin Luther King, poor people, church of love at the time. He had a storefront on Pstri and a young had an office on the 45th floor almost across the street.
But he, that manuscript is still sitting with his family that we were going to do. So my book was the only one. But he led that March on the Selma-to-Montgomery marches with John R. Lewis.
And Dr. King came month and a half later to UCLA. And had I not gone, I don't think I would have gone south. But Dr. King was so impressive that I was ready to go, but still afraid.
And it took actually a friend to confront me, another Jewish friend from, I played football with at high school. And he was going and he said, why don't you come. And I had no excuse except I'm scared, which I was.
I was waiting to be a counselor in a prison, but I'd gotten the thing saying you're too young. You can't be a counselor in a prison until you're 21. But I had been interested in, in being a social worker at that time in my life. Just sort of what I did in my life anyway.
And so Dr. King made a, made an appeal at UCLA made the national announcement. And they had a Joel Siegel was one of the Rick key organizers, Richard "Rick" Tuttle, another key organizer.
Even if he didn't want to talk about it in your interview, but, but and he was actually our advisor. He was our, you know, he was an old man of 25 at that time. We were all 18 and 19 and 20.
And Rick was kind of our on campus advisor. In fact, when I was arrested in America with John R. Lewis and others of the UCLA group were with us, the pictures are in the book, front page news. I have the video from CBS NBC, ABC, which Joel got me.
Rick actually was connected enough politically at that time to get to Glenn M. Anderson, who was Lieutenant Governor for Edmund G. "Pat" Brown, Edmund G. "Pat" Brown was out of the state.
And, and Glenn M. Anderson telegramed Carl Sanders and said, we have five UCLA students missing in Americus. Because in those days when you, when you got arrested, like the guys in Mississippi, you didn't know whether you were going to go out in the country. In fact, my first arrest in Americus, I was the happiest civil rights worker when they toured towards the jail and not towards the country. That, that's why that was my, I wasn't so worried about getting arrested. I was worried that I might not go to jail.
And so Rick, Rick did that. There was one point of telegram with my name and the other's names that Rick arranged. So Rick was very involved with scope, disturbing divine worship. I went two weeks. I went first, first week, just me and John, maybe there's some other people behind me and John were in front. And the fire chief was actually quite an interesting experience. I've told him many times.
I went to Americus from Macon, Hosea Williams wanted people to go down to see a hot movement. And I think because of my athletic background and being little, I had to, you know, they talk about giving 110%. When you're five, eight hundred and forty pounds, most of the guys are six feet and bigger. If you look at my teams, I'm always one of the smaller ones, although in high school, it was kind of a small team, although we had, you know, let's say half of us were small comparatively to the guys over six feet.
You work harder. You have to work harder or you can't compete. And I wasn't as gifted. I was good enough to be with the most gifted in LA, but at the bottom of the group. And the only reason I was with the most gifted and when I say most gifted, there's a Steve Sogge who played quarterback at USC. And then for Brooklyn Dodgers, Jeff Pentland + Tom Griffin, who was on my team, who played 12 years in the big league, Jeff Pentland + Jeff Pentland + Tom Griffin, who was in the Hall of Famine, Arizona State was a semi-social sitting coach with the, getting coach for Brooklyn Dodgers now with Seattle.
I mean, there's a difference. Those guys end up in the big leagues and in the Hall of Fame. Guys like me, if we work real hard, we can compete with them. And so I wasn't that gift. I was good. I mean, some guys don't make the team. I made the team. So I was good enough to do that.
But so I was at the bottom run of the best in LA, which is good. So I could play when I integrated the making bombers and that league and making.
So what we were talking about is, is the UCLA thing. So Dr. King came, are we back on? So Dr. King came. Joel Siegel really was taking the lead, raised some money. Dr. King had a lunch at URC, University of Religious Conference.
And for people who don't know if Tanya tells you Joel Siegel is?
Joel Siegel at that time was the humor editor of the Daily Bruin and was in Calps, which is a spirit organization. And as he said, I later became Joel Siegel, I'm good morning America entertainment editor.
And if you did one piece in Israel as well, he did some, he did a little other journalism, but mainly he's known for entertainment and movie reviews, which he was very successful at. Very well loved that.
He came over to Queens College when I published this book. We did a program there. UCLA has never done a program for my book. Joel would have flown out for one. They refused.
But weren't interested. What interested for six years in doing even a plaque for Dr. King and only did it because they were ordered to Queens College in braces. That's where Andy Goodman went to school. That's one of, one that was killed with James, James, Cheney and Mickey Schwerner.
So Dr. King, I remember there were two things in a speech. I'd be happy to tell you that really impressed me when I listened to it. I hadn't, again, not yet decided. I would volunteer, but wanted to and felt it was the right thing to do.
You want to know the two things that impressed me. One thing he talked about the three versions of love in Greek, a Goppy Filia and an Aros as a teenager with hormones. I was very familiar with the Aros, but the Goppy and Filia were totally new concepts to me.
And very interesting topics that you could divide love in the other things because at that point, Aros is pretty overwhelming when you're 18. The hormones were there. And of course, I loved my family and I had friends that were women that I didn't think of in sexual ways, but that was a pretty macho playboy time culture for young males in America.
So that was very interesting to me. And also it was a way of understanding and putting into a theoretical context why I was interested and upset that people were being mistreated because they weren't showing a Goppy or Filia.
And that was what supposedly America was about. Land of the free home of the brave out of many one. What could be more Filia and a Goppy than that.
So the other thing was he had a great sense of humor because Dr. King about halfway through his speech, he was talking about the history, many of the good things that had happened. And he said, I could stop here.
He said, but first of all, Baptist preachers don't give short sermons and everybody laughed, of course. And he said, but I need to tell you the other part too that there's a lot more work to do.
And he was just a likable guy. Carrot, not he wasn't giving the kind of oration that he gave in the March. I mean, I have the tape that I got before. I think it's now restricted. I don't think he could get it from audiovisual UCLA. But before then I did get a copy. And actually I provided UCLA with a transcript that I paid for without any thanks.
But he was he was a person. And of course, Franklin Murphy introduced him and he said, this is I think when legend meets reality. And he said, this is the moral leader of our country.
Franklin Murphy was taking somewhat of a risk because the FBI was going around every place that invited Dr. King and trying to sabotage it. And I mean, because I wrote the report to President Reagan and the Congress on the first King holiday for Coretta Scott King. And I read all the congressional testimony.
And since researching David J. Garrow's slimy, sleazy book using Hoover's Files, which Taylor Branch also does. And I think a very disreputable way.
Have researched much of this from the 19 volumes that are at the UCLA Library of the House Assassinations Commission report, who they start out that report by saying we hesitate to include many of these files.
But so the reader has an understanding we are including them, but we are cautioning the reader that these represent a shameful chapter in American history. And these are unverified attributions towards people's personal lives and political affiliations.
Which is never found in Taylor Branch's book or David J. Garrow's book after they heavily quote those same files. They quote the same files that the Congress investigated with hundreds of thousands of dollars over many years, produced a report 19 volumes.
But then they and in my book that that's some part of is in that book went to Cass Canfield in Harper and Row. And he wanted it, but he wanted me to put sex things in just as Holt, Rinehart and Winston did just as many New York publishers want to sell books.
I said no. Taylor Branch David J. Garrow said yes. They won Pulitzer Prizes. I did. I was on Tony Brown and he said this is after Gierro's book. He said Mr. Leventhal, you're challenging the Pulitzer Prize.
Some people may say you're jealous of David J. Garrow because he won it and you didn't. I was a little caught off guard because Tony Brown and I had actually arranged which he didn't want me to say on camera, but he had worked with me a little bit on the background of our interview.
But it was still a challenge to go on national TV and be talking about Dr. King's personal life at all because it's not something that anybody's business in my opinion.
But I said well, but I wasn't expecting that question. I said well you know I would be just honest if I said I wouldn't have loved or wouldn't love to win a Pulitzer Prize for a book I did on Dr. King, but I would not want a Pulitzer Prize for that book.
I would not want anything to do with that book. A Pulitzer Prize is not more important to me than telling the truth and not using these kinds of files.
So, but anyway that's a long answer to that visit by Dr. King. There was a committee set up. Joel again was very involved. Richard "Rick" Tuttle, I'm sure Rick me had mentioned Alex White to you. I don't know if he did, but Alex White who's not in good health now was ran the service organization at UCLA to send people to internships.
Alex was involved at the time and I was just a freshman and of course my excuse to myself was when I was not going to do it because I was afraid I was like oh I'm just a freshman.
I kept thinking of reasons they've got a lot of people I'm sure I'm just a freshman. They got better people than me when the real wasn't going to go down there. They're going to kill me just like they did the guys last summer.
But when my friend confronted me I just had that decision and that was my whole life up till then. Hearing the kite words Jackie Robinson, you know the March on Washington, some black friends I had.
I did write what I told Harris Wofford, I did write an editorial or only sports for my high school paper except two articles. One was about cigarette smoking because my mom had already had an operation for lung cancer and she died three years later from lung cancer and the stress of me being in the movement I think was not particularly good for her.
I was very personal experience for me in that sense that I put stress on my family by making the decision to get involved and stay involved.
My dad was very happy that I went he wasn't that bad I stayed involved after I came back after three arrests and so on. Because he said you've done your part. You served your tour you don't have to keep doing this and I said well they've asked me to be the college coordinator.
I was very involved I think it was a very religious thing for me as well. I think I found a real religious connection to my Judaism and the Judaism was a big connection to the explanation of how to respond to anti-Semitism.
Can I ask you to talk a little bit more about that first thing because I often feel that people's civil rights experiences are very much like a conversion experience.
What they experience there and how they relate to it.
I wanted to finish there was one other one I mean what I'll eventually wander back to it later but not so much of a conversion that there's a letter in that book that I was it was a letter I wrote to my then roommate Charlie Goldberg who he took it to the day of broom and they published it.
And I've actually heard it from some of the other people that were in the scope project. I had not been around a lot of black people only two were in my high school I played baseball and football against the kids from San Fernando,
Pacoima were Mexican and black at that time. And so I didn't have a lot of personal experience. The editorial in the high school paper I do want to talk about that first.
That came about because Grant at that time was a very TV Hollywood kind of place. Tom Selleck there for good basketball player track guy. James Keach + James Keach + Stacy Keach was a good friend of mine.
I was up the road here. I was married to Jane Seymour, Dr. Quinn. James did a great movie about Johnny Cash and the long writers with his brother Stacy.
Many other Hollywood people one of whom was a guy named Kim Weiskopf who's dad wrote I love Lucy. Kim being well to do went to a Beverly Hills camp.
One of the counselors was a black guy who went to Cal State LA was all American football player Cal State when they still had football team.
I went to a party one that summer my junior summer with Kim and this African American and those age would have said Degro guy was there.
Nice guy in the world. Great singer. He sang at the party. I got a meeting. Nice guy in the world. Then Proposition 14 was on the ballot in 64 which was the anti discrimination housing thing which which loss by the way and the Rumford Fair Housing Act.
It's got then declared I believe unconstitutional. The other editorial beside smoking was about this African American young man who I named at the time. I don't remember his name anymore. It's still in the grand odyssey files.
I was with my friend Kim Weiskopf who was the photographer for the paper later went in and wrote good times and created a full house. 9 to 5 married with children.
I died recently not too long with cancer sadly but had a great career in Hollywood. Followed his father. Norman Lear got him his first job. Nice when you get your father's friends and Norman Lear.
Kim took me to the party and I said I was at a party with Kim. I met this guy. He's a great guy. He's an all-American football player. He's a great student. He sings great. I said but some people went to him for a neighbor because he's Negro.
I was mature enough at 17 to say I think it was one of the better things I've ever written. I told Harris I said I think I was with the march on Washington in spirit. I was mature enough to write that article based on my friendship with him.
The conversion to go back to your question was when we then went to the south there was an immersion into the black community.
Those of us who wanted to feel we looked at everybody the same. You can't look at everybody the same if you're only around white people because black people look different.
Not better, worse. Just the same thing I would say with gay people. It's not better, worse. It's different. I don't know why we can't just say people can be different.
That's okay. That doesn't mean we don't like them. It doesn't mean we're homophobic. We just say a marriage between a man and a man and a woman and a woman is different.
It doesn't have to be the same. I've always felt, pick a new word. Say it's my loved one. This is my loved one. I mean I think we should change it all.
Men and women should say this is my loved one. Take the word marriage away because that offends older conservative people who don't hate people but hate that they're losing what they consider is very sacred for generations and history and blah blah blah what they said at the Supreme Court.
I thought the discussion was pretty good. I think we should get away from marriage and that everybody talk about their loved one.
Some people's loved ones are their children like Dr. King, a Goppy Philly, an arrows. You can have arrows for the man, arrows for the woman. I don't care.
I hate to see all this division and pain about the subject as somebody with this background and people have suggested that get the state out of it.
But I think we should have a new word for it. Not marriage, my loved one. My loved one. And just say some things are different.
And again it's different when you're not around Black people. The great story is in other people that I've now Sherry LeBetus who's written a new book, another woman who's writing a book, Maria Gitin University Alabama about scope, scope workers after my effort to for organize our first SNCCAS reunion every year.
Multiple ones, every 10 years, 50 years. The Attorney General comes to their reunion. I had one reunion. We've only in scope had one ever.
There was a professor from Albany, New York who did his group in South Carolina. Andy N came because it was in Atlanta and Andy's my friend. And he's so nice to have come.
And that's what I got an article in the United States Constitution. Fox News was going to come but we quit a little too early.
But a number of us have said it was so different when we immersed in the Black community. And within a few weeks Black people would just look normal.
They weren't different anymore because we saw them every day. And then they didn't all look the same either because they're all different shades.
They have different lips, different noses, different, just like white people. We're all different. But with the skin colors, different hues.
And in fact, the great story, there's a young man, not anymore, but at the time, who worked from Carlisle, Carlisle, Pennsylvania, forgetting the college.
David said I can't remember the name, but anyway, he had the same experience I did. And he said when he knew it was time to go, he stayed extra like I did.
He said, he stayed till November. And he said his mother called him and he thought, why is this white woman calling me? And he said, he said, that's wrong.
He said, I knew I needed a break at that time. And I know for me the way I describe it is in the beginning, the Black people look different.
By the end of the summer, the White people look different. I didn't think I was Black, but Black people were my friends. Black people were my baseball teammates.
The white people literally wanted to kill me and did try and kill me. So the white people look different to me. And just within three months, it shows how my background is sociology, it shows how a cultureation.
So one of the conversions is that emotionally, and I said in that letter, I used to want and used to believe I wasn't prejudiced since everybody the same.
But now I really feel that way because I know Black people. I know more Black people than I used to in those days, Negroes.
And so that's one part of the conversion is that when you have so many Black friends and you're living with a Black family, that becomes your life.
And you have no more doubts that you're going to treat people different because they're Black.
Because everybody's Black, that you're new. So they become, and then the young, beautiful Black women become young, beautiful women.
And the good athletes become good athletes and the color fades to very little significant at that point.
So let me just ask you where you went if you could just tell if they could create that.
Yeah, so the way the scope project was organized, the board of SCLC at Hosea Williams request, and he developed the project, which is in my book, Scope of Freedom, the founding papers, essentially.
Proved it in December and they targeted 120 counties. They didn't target. It was much like a battle plan. Hosea Williams was a World War II veteran, was in General George Patton's, what they call the Negro.
Tank Brigade, a great friend of mine, Jim Colaianni, who was a Catholic leader, lay leader, who was at that time executive editor of Ramparts with Jann Wenner.
Jann Wenner tried to convince him to go partners with this new magazine that he was going to start. I think it was called Rolling Stone.
But Jan was only like 21 and Jim said, yeah, yeah, and that's really cool. But we grownups are doing other stuff.
So he didn't, he didn't found Rolling Stone with Jann Wenner. But Jan worked at at Ramparts as a young, young kid.
But Jim started a business and did sermons, which I think his son is still doing. I think Jim is still alive in New Jersey, it must be in his 80s.
He was also a World War II veteran. I did his daughter very briefly, Karen Colaianni Johnson, who I met through somebody in the American campaign,
he had all these connections through politics and civil rights.
And the reason I bring up Jim is he did an issue of Ramparts about Selma, and he did it in a military way where he had a joint chiefs of staff almost on the white side, Jim Clark, the black side doctor, King.
But he did it as a military battle. And that was very outproposing. And very brilliant. That's the spring issue of Ramparts magazine somewhere in the library.
But Hosea Williams really had kind of a battle plan. And the picked 120 counties, which were listed in the book, these were not the worst 120 counties.
These were the 120 counties where if they got another 30 or 40% Negro voters, they could knock out the racist and get into moderate.
Some of the counties like Lowndes County, Alabama, there was no blacks at all. I mean, you had a longer road. That's why Lowndes County Freedom Organization (LCFO) → Black Panther Party was appropriate in many, many ways and a very good thing in Mississippi and many places.
Because you have to move outside the party. Dr. King and scope and Andrew Young, and they wanted to move within the Democratic Party and overturn the worst racist counties.
And Andrew Young has told me that those same 120 scope counties all went for Barack Obama and may have made the difference in the election 2008.
You can talk to Andy about that, whether I haven't seen those statistics in his congressional, I mean his governor's campaign in Georgia, the scope counties in South Georgia also again were counties that came out heavily for him.
Many of those are also worse scope and snickered together. But they wanted 2000 volunteers to man these 120 counties, they only got 500.
So when people tell you, well, it was all over, it didn't have nothing going on. More people got killed in the year of 65 as civil rights workers than in 64.
It was still quite dangerous. I'm sure Cheryl Sharad will verify that and other people from Southwest Georgia.
And so, and also at that point, whites were getting killed because blacks were starting to shoot back. That happened in America.
Unfortunately, a bystander who was white, who had Andrew Whatley, who I consider a martyr of the movement, who had just joined the Marines, was a bystander when they were throwing rocks at the marchers.
And there was a black car. A car came with two black guys. They weren't part of the movement and they were tired of people being abused and they shot back.
I got shot at twice in America because we didn't get to shoot back. That wasn't part of our thing. But there are many snick people that were carrying guns by them.
But not, in fact, I tell the story in my article, I think you saw for Benay Muth Magazine, Judson Ford, a Korean War vet. It took a 38 in his belt when we were going out to get kids. We're not in a demonstration now.
There was a transition period going through deignants for defense and justice in Louisiana. We're already openly carrying guns. But within the movement, within Dr. King during demonstrations, et cetera, that was our philosophy. And that was a philosophy of scope.
Did you go through a specific training?
Yeah. But you asked to where I was. Absolutely. The orientation schedule was in there was fascinating. But because we only could get 500, because of the danger, that's why people didn't volunteer.
And it was almost all white and not just, you know, there were many blacks in the South. Not too many blacks were coming out of the North to go South. Stoney Cooks was one.
And I hope you get a chance to talk to Stony in Washington. But Stony could tell you about that. But Jesse Jackson was another who came into Selma at that time. That was when he got involved with SCLC in Selma. Not in the leadership role, by the way. That came later.
But Stony did have a leadership role very quickly. The people with skills and media, there's a lady named Kit Clark, who I just saw about with scope, whose papers are now at the Schomburg.
She had some skills. She went to leadership role in scope with Hosea Williams Hosea Williams was good at picking people. He picked me. So I don't know. Hopefully that was a good pick also.
But so we couldn't man the whole 120 counties. We went essentially into 90 counties. They had black leaders in all the 20 counties that had requested people. They were working.
And some of us were shifted around. I worked in two counties primarily, but went into four or five other counties for demonstrations.
So that was, they sent out recruiting teams between Selma, between the first of the year, while Selma was going on. They had recruiting teams all around the country, ecologists.
And Dr. King himself was the recruiter, UCLA. So I always got to tell people, Dr. King recruited me. Not Hosea Williams, not Andy. I said, Dr. King recruited me. So I don't have to answer to you guys so much as you might want me to.
And I think he also knew that I had been picked because I had talked to him personally, got the thinking when they called us in for a meeting.
But so we went to Atlanta. We were housed at Morehouse College in the dorms. I had, I've recently said I may have learned more and one week at Morse Brown than at six years with a BA and MA, UCLA.
Particularly now the way I feel about UCLA and what they've done with the scope history and taking down Dr. King's photo and Franklin Murphy's photo from that wonderful day when Dr. King back to honor by the way, Jackie Robinson and Ralph Butch, who the UCLA people love to make money on and market, particularly Jackie Robinson.
And Rachel Robinson does not know this, but I hope to tell her before too. And I just missed her at the civil rights game, sat across from her with Andy and went after the thing that she left early. But I'll see, I'll see Mrs. Robinson at some point.
Andy knows, but you know, there's only so many battles you fight at. I mean, this is my battle. I got the plaque up anyway for his visit.
But so we have this wonderful orientation. If you're having the book, or I'll tell you who was there at the orientation, it's amazing, amazing. I consider it the best week of education in American history. That's a big statement. Let me tell you who was there. Dr. King spoke to us.
Bayard Rustin organized A. Philip Randolph, Hosea Williams spoke to us and was at one of the organizers. Norman Hill, who had been at core, was Bayard's assistant. Then we had people like C. Vann Woodward, John Hope Franklin from academia.
Lillian Smith was there, didn't speak. We also had Septima Clark, who started the citizenship of education schools. We had Vernon E. Jordan Jr. We had Charles "Chuck" Morgan Jr from, from what the legal organization, ACLU, national leader.
We had Clarence M. Mitchell Jr from the end of LACP, the head of the office there. We had the field staff who were in it. We had Michael Harrington, the other America, which was a key book about poverty.
We had a number of government people. We had a Jewish man who was head of the meat packers union, whose picture is in there. Why am I forgetting his name? He was there.
John Doar came down. He's not in the schedule, but he came down and told us how to make reports to him, which Joel Siegel did when my life was threatened, which resulted in 33 gas stations getting desegregated in three states.
John Doar had trained us and John Doar ordered J. Edgar Hoover to investigate. Once that happened, the FBI did a very good investigation, which is recorded in my FBI file that's in the book.
It was an extraordinary week. I've forgotten a few people, but just the people I mentioned to you, it's a pretty all-star cast of people to speak to us in a week. Dr. King addressed us.
He was a waging thing about Dr. King's speech when he closed with free at last, he said, like in watch and watching, he said Jews and Gentiles, Black and White Protestant cast Jews and Gentiles.
When he spoke to us, knowing that there were young people, someone who might be atheists or agnostic, he said Muslims and Hindus and non-believers.
Now, here, because he had been to India, he knew about Pakistan and the Muslim and the Hindus fighting there and he knew about Kashmir and I've talked to Kash, and the young has been to Kashmir.
He was happy that I even knew about Kashmir because I'm not a global person. But to me, given our world now with the things that are going on the world and the Islamic world, and still with Pakistan and India,
that Dr. King went out of his way to say that and that recording available, by the way, that was at Morehouse College in Jodo, as Chimnasium. Such a far-reaching visionary thing to talk about to a college group.
Now, as we look at it, he was talking about we need to heal these divisions of race and religion, and not just among Jews and Gentiles, among Hindus and Muslims.
Although in those days we called, I don't know how those days it was Muslim, but we've changed it to Muslim, but he said Muslim and Hindu.
And I know the reason he said it was because of Gandhi in India and Pakistan. So it was an amazing week. We're all energized, originally, as with a number of chapters, the gentleman Larry Scott Butler is the one who talked about his mom, and he had a lot of similar experience.
He went off to Bogalusa, Louisiana, Louisiana and the man at the house where he stayed had a gun, same thing. He said, my daughter is here because Larry Scott Butler said the same thing.
We're nonviolence. He might be, and the man is going to kill my daughter. And what Andrew Young always said, he said, if it had not been for nonviolence, the South would have been like Northern Ireland.
He said, because everybody in the South in rural areas, they all hunt, and most of the people who have been in World War II, and everybody had guns.
Yeah, from Korea and World War II. Wasn't that long after World War 15 years after World War II, or 20 years after World War II.
So if you look at it that way, both SNCC and the NSCLC through nonviolence, you could say they saved the country because if we had been like Northern Ireland at that, that pint in our history with African-Cugging becoming independent, I always tell people, this was about America.
One of the Swedish guys who was at the Co-op, I ran on the All You Cross Country Championship team for Intermurals.
And it was me, a guy who was a very good runner and a guy from Sweden. And he told me, he said, one of my mother, and he talked about when in Europe, when they saw headlines about Alabama, wasn't about Alabama, it was about America.
And when Russia was saying, follow us independent countries, we're the great country, we're socialism, everybody's taking care of.
And we said, no, follow us, it's we're about freedom. And yet we weren't about freedom to a significant number. It was the VOA, we have, you know, it's a great, and that's why when I'm in Montgomery, I try to tell the whites in the blacks.
And many of the whites, they just re, they just overwhelmingly in the Senate and the House passed resolutions in Alabama to pardon the Scottsboro boys.
Without one dissenting vote, not one, the governor's going to sign it.
And, and they've now recognized and embraced this was for everybody. This movement, and many of the whites say it, it freed the whites, it freed us from our guilt.
And it freed us from the terrorism of the clan, you know. And there were many whites who stood up, Clifford Durr + Virginia Durr + Aubrey Williams, wonderful people, you know, who really had some courage, because they lived there the whole time.
We left, you know, because we weren't living there. Some of us stayed a little longer, whatever. I'm one of the few that's moved there. And I like Alabama now. And Alabama has changed a great deal, great deal.
And I'll try and be shorter to respond to your questions. Well, let me mention one of their Pearson, Alabama is Millard Fuller from, from Lanett, Alabama and his wife, Linda Fuller from Montgomery, who started Habitat, who I met, I wrote the first article about Millard in housing, because that started at Koinonia Farm, Sun Chin acres, that's where it started.
And I actually did my R&R out of America, it's over at Coenania for a couple days. So we got out of jail, they took us out there, and met Clarence L. Jordan, who was the father, you know, the founder of that place, and I became very close friends with Florence, by the way, the uncle of Hamilton, five Jordan brothers, one integrationist, that was Clarence, and who knew Hamilton Jordan quite well, and Hamilton knew his uncle Clarence quite well.
And I think that's what I wanted to do, and I think that was really, as you say, a R&R place for movement.
Well, it was its own place, too. I mean, they had their own history, but they do that in all of any two, they went up to Coenania today.
I got to swim in a water hole, something that a boy from California, two big country things I had in the South. One was the water hole of Coenania.
The other was that my first baseball game with the Macon Bombers in Round Oak, Georgia, which was in the middle of a cow pasture that had been, trees had been cut down, and there were cow patties on the baseball field.
This was not something that a boy from LA who played on pretty good baseball fields, which used to be because my mind said, what if the ball hits the cow patty?
Country boys don't care about that stuff. And, of course, the ball didn't hit the cow patty.
But that's a good segue, too. So, you know, would take us past the orientation to your assignment?
Yes, we had the orientation. It was an incredible orientation. And like, and the same thing with Larry Butler, the reason I say,
originally they got assigned one place. We got assigned to Bibb County, which was small, but we had the one of the biggest group for the 20.
Brandeis had a big group, which they don't seem to be interested in, or my Jewish brother in, don't seem to be interested in, small college had his biggest clubby, you say, LA Berkeley.
I'm working on that, and they will get interested, I guarantee you, in the next couple of years, or they will be very embarrassed, maybe this may embarrass them.
But Jonathan D. Sarna, who's the guy who spoke at the May-Britth Convention, who's the advisor to the National Jewish Museum, is there, I gave him the book, he hasn't called me back yet.
I would deal with Dr. Sarna, who's very important, distinguished, and of course, Woller-Levent, all of this is not, he dropped out before he got his PhD, you say, LA, but this is my mission, and you're giving me a little form for it, so I appreciate that.
But, so, yeah, that was the reason, and they also wanted to assign us where they could get some numbers, which was Macon, Georgia, where they had a great local leader, a great local leader, William P. Randall, William P. Randall was one.
They had a name man named Tom Jackson, became the first black judge, who was the only black lawyer in town, there weren't many in Georgia at that time, and he went south, he returned south, and he became a good friend, he was also a former semi-pro baseball player, and of course, his family, and his wife's family, thought they were completely crazy to go south.
He knew Mr. (William P.) Randall, and he went back, and he courageous guy, and there was also a guy named Lewis Wynn, many others, there was NAACP Youth Council, but Mr. (William P.) Randall was the town leader, he was a great guy.
Joel Siegel talked about him on Good Morning America, he was somewhat of a mentor to Joel, although Joel never went back either, a lot of people, once they left they didn't want to go back for whatever reasons I did, because I became friends with Hosea Williams and Andy, and Mr. (William P.) Randall, and Joel went back and did a great, great piece for Good Morning America.
That was kind of the field producer up, but so my position was, the SCLC, we're on assignment from them, that's where they want to go, that's where we went, wasn't a great discussion, but there was some Romanicism, and also maybe we're needed more in the rural areas, but that soon ended when Hosea Williams said you are ordered to go to America, I am the general, you are the troops, you go where I tell you, that's the way it works there, and that's what we did.
There was no discussion that they had and snake that whites were taking control, Hosea Williams made it very clear, who was in charge, Willie Bolden, who was an ex-Marine and a very tough guy.
There was no cognitive dissonance about who was going to be running anything, SCLC ran it, Hosea Williams ran it and his troops ran it, and we learned, and if we did well, we got asked to join the staff, and then we had a little more stature on the staff, but there was no confusion in our group.
Hosea Williams ran it, we didn't have that problem, and William P. Randall ran it, and there was some, anyway, so that was one thing, Larry Scott Butler's group was a great story, was that, I got to tell this story, and Larry Scott is down in Florida.
They got assigned to some county, and then SCLC said no, Hosea Williams said we need you, or the guy that was Hosea Williams's guy there, I think is a minister here, I think is named River and Harrow, so no, we need you to go to Clayton, Alabama, Barbour County, Alabama, Alabama.
But we already talked to these people here, we need, they were expecting us, they said, Barbour County, Alabama is the home of George C. Wallace, we need you to go raise Helen, George C. Wallace, and they said they immediately said, when do we leave?
And they had big demonstrations, they tore that town up, and apparently George C. Wallace came down one time, and his comment was, he said at the auto repair place, watch them march to the courthouse, and he said, that's the best look, and best dress, best dress groups, a civil rights worker I've ever seen.
Because we were told, and one of the reasons that snick didn't like us, because we were told not to have beards, told to look more preppy, and to be careful about holding interracial couples in public, because it's not a criticism of the snick, they were courageous, wonderful people, but they made the white people even angrier because they flaunted it sometimes, not that it didn't need to be flaunted in some sense, but it also could get people hurt and killed, and so on.
And that wasn't a value, that was one of our roles, if we got killed, that brought the media and that changed things, that's a sad thing to say, but black people's lives weren't too important in those days.
So we were told to dress well, well George C. Wallace noticed, that's the best dress group of civil rights workers I ever saw.
Apparently, I mean that's what Larry Scott Bother told me, that was his only car, which I think is hilarious, but they registered a lot of people, that was one of the second most active movements in scope.
Americus was probably the first, and there are all the incidents reports in that book, there's about 20 pages of incidents reports, not everything made the incidents reports.
Be happy to.
The scope of freedom, the leadership of Hosea Williams William of the Dr. King, Summer 65 student volunteers, there's Hosea Williams and Andy and St. Augustine, where Jackie Robinson by the way was, as long Jackie Robinson was in Birmingham, Jackie Robinson was in all Benny, as they call it, did Charles Sherrod, because then he talked about Jackie Robinson.
Jackie, Jackie went there at Dr. King's request after the churches were burned, and they couldn't, and they couldn't get the media.
I have an interview with Andrew Young in the book you have about that, but I have this great photo of Jackie Robinson with a white T Walker in Albany near a burned out church, and Andy said in the interview, said if you want to talk about being in harm's way, being in rural Southwest Georgia, after the churches have been burned out.
The churches have been burned out by the clan, that's as much harm's way as you can be in those days, because you're not in a demonstration, they had the media there, but there's Jackie.
Didn't have to be there, he's from Cairo, Georgia, not too far from there, but he was on the front lines over and over again.
One of the reasons he's doing more of my hero now, and I think that I know more about him than when I was young, but he was a healer, and God bless him.
I'm glad he's getting the recognition. God bless Bud Selig. I got his meat bud through Andy, that's one reason Bud would want to meet me really, not that he's just because he has too many other things to do.
He's a nice man, he's done a great job retiring Jackie's number, Harrison Ford did a great job with this movie, and young people of all races need to know, here's a celebrity.
He wasn't worried about the bling, he wasn't worried about tweeting, he didn't have his own reality show, although he did play himself in a wonderful movie, Jackie Robinson's story.
Typical of that era of Hollywood, well meaning, but a little hokey at places. But still a good movie, and you get to see Jackie himself, and Ruby Dee, who's Rachel Robinson, is wonderfully attractive woman as a Ruby Dee playing Jackie Robinson's wife.
But such a special guy, such a lesson for, and these young ball players are now learning it.
I've just read the MLB blog, and Bryce Harper + Bryce Harper + Matt Kemp saw the movie at the White House, Prokobama showed 42, Bryce Harper + Bryce Harper + Matt Kemp was in Thuse, Bryce Harper + Matt Kemp, and you know, it's baseball has a special role in all this.
Because of Jackie and Branch Ricky, and as Jackie said in his book, I never had it made, this was Branch Ricky's deal. I was just an actor in Branch Ricky's deal. I mean Branch Ricky conceived it all.
So can you tell us about the role that baseball played for you that summer?
Oh sure, I'm talking about baseball I love. It's actually an interesting story, which hopefully will be on a big screen or a small screen at some point.
But it's ironic, that was going to be my first summer not playing baseball since I was 10 years old.
I had been discouraged, my high school team went to the city finals, and I had played it on that, I played American Legion as a 15 year old in South Bay, where I had been the all area shortstop.
I played, you had to get asked to be on that team after high school, and my teammates and their family are two dads, both who played professional baseball, the kids, Jeff Pentland + Jeff Pentland + Tom Griffin, and Ron McMacKinn is a buddy of Mark McGwire, Galsville Mark McGwire, and Tiger Woods.
Very successful bunch of guys, and great athletes.
You know, they're dads, and they call my parents, it means you won't willing to play on the American Legion team.
It was a very fast group, they'd come in third in the state and little league, they're very good.
But that summer I didn't play with them, they asked me to play, and I was getting ready for school, and I was kind of burned out because I got hurt both years, and to get much playing time.
Now I really regret it, they went to the state finals in Yalfill in American Legion, and went on to great things in baseball.
I had been on five pros on the high school team, and two more that turned down contracts, which is very rare.
That's like a division one, 11 division one athletes on my high school baseball team, two in the big leagues.
So I played with good guys, I had been around good baseball players, not realizing at the time how good they were, because I was more discouraged, because I wasn't playing.
In fact, my high school coach told me, I said, I'm going to UCLA, do you think I can play there? He said, oh yeah, you couldn't play at USC, but you can play at UCLA.
I'm not thinking, what the hell are you talking about? I'm not playing here, but as a matter of fact, our high school team was better than UCLA.
By the time my friends were in college, they were in the Hall of Fame, Santa Barbara, Arizona State, they beat UCLA every time they played the pitchers, the pitchers were our strong suit, our fourth pitcher pitch double-lay baseball.
So I played good baseball, I wasn't going to play that summer.
When I came back, I got asked to actually go out at UCLA by a guy named Ray Earrington who's in the Hall of Fame, because they heard about that I played in the South, because it was in my letter.
But there was a guy named Willie Bowens, who still works at the VA. He came back with us. He was the one that was not invited to the opening of the Martin Luther King Memorial along with everybody else.
I tried to tell, they had the name for a title and I developed the list.
And he was an African-American, it worked three miles away. He didn't get invited. I wouldn't go. They finally invited me, but I said, if you don't invite everybody, I'm not going.
I didn't care that much about having my little day of glory among the UCLA group that had been opposed to having a Black for Dr. King for six years.
I only did it because they were forced to by the NAACP and the President of the University, Mark Yudof, who hasn't forced them to put the picture back up yet.
Willie Bowens was one of our young recruits. Some had worked with the NAACP Youth Council. Others came into the movement that summer because William P. Randall took us around to a different church every night the first week.
We had a mass meeting, you know, what mass meetings are. And he introduced us. These white people have come down here. These white students here from UCLA, Dr. King did this, was they William P. Randall was a special, special wonderful man.
Later became, there's a building name for him, his Joel Siegel said, good morning, America. He later became a Bibb County Commissioner. His son was the first state representative, his granddaughter is now the state representative and his son is a judge.
So things do change and have changed, but Bill was the leader in the town, wonderful, just an e-man.
And so we started recruiting young people from all the different parts of town. In Willie Bowens came out of East Macon, which is where I ended up living with the Simmons family.
Terrell Simmons was on the Bibb Bombers as well, but I didn't know that at the time. He was gone. There was no father in home. That was a little bit of the scandal I later found because this Simmons took in two white boys and each had two daughters still at home.
One was at Tuskegee University already, now in Mali and things are not going well in Mali. So Lucille, I'm in touch with her by email, a case of not recently. I should find out what's going on with her, but she's literally lets me know if there's a problem.
But anyway, so Terrell was on the team, but Willie Bowens and I became good buddies. Also William C. Randall, who was William P. Randall's nephew, later had a terrible car accident, but William C. and Willie and I, and of course I used to have one thing I really liked,
there were lots of willies. There was one time I was in a front yard and it was me and Willie Bowens, and the guy we were trying to get to register with, his name was Willie and the cousin's name was Willie.
And I wrote the thing, I said lots of willies. I said, one thing that's Willie's feel is that all people are created, well, equal except Willie's, work created more equal, because I was thinking of Willie Willie Mays because he was such a great athlete.
But anyway, so Willie and I got to be buddies, Willie's on the make, Willie Bowens was on the make and bombers, and he said, hey, maybe I can get you a try out.
I used to wear my football jerseys in the picture here from the scope book. I was stupid enough to actually wear it in the marches, and there I, which I think now, there was a great target for the clan.
I was like, one of the only white guys, and I'm wearing a bullseye, but I was also doing it to relate to the guys through athletics, which was my strong suit.
So I used to call me number 10 a little bit later on in the make, because I wore my football jerseys, and I was proud I had been on the football team.
So, the bombers were in make, sometimes they're called the Bibb Bombers as well.
There's an article in, I think that book I showed you, with Terrell's picture in me. Terrell and I did this program, but the Georgia Sports Hall of Fame on the make and bombers, because they had into traveling exhibit on baseball and black and white about the Negro Leagues.
And they also had, of course, they had the Negro Leagues, and they had a lot of local Negro Leagues, because they couldn't have black white Leagues, as well as they had their own Leagues.
So, Willie got me a trial, and so we went out. Terrell had the team bus, which Terrell always worked two or three jobs. Terrell sadly had a heart attack about five years ago now, passed away, but I would always stay with Terrell.
To people I would always see in Atlanta first were Terrell and Hosea Williams, and I would usually stand Terrell's couch.
When I wrote the report to the President of the Congress, I stayed on Terrell's couch for two or three months, worked for Coretta Scott King.
And I gave some money, I gave $400 back to the holiday commission, which didn't have public funding.
Partly because Terrell gave me free rent, so I had a little extra in. They didn't have much money.
Lloyd Davis, who was my supervisor there, was a federal bureaucrat. Wonderful man, worked for Sargent Shriver, worked through Republican side when they passed the King Holiday in Reagan, signed it.
And his eyes got very big, you're giving me money back. It's like nobody gives money back, this is the federal government, but we didn't have federal money yet.
We did later get it, and had it been federal money, I wouldn't have given it back, but we didn't have much money, and it was private money.
And I just never wanted people to think that I was doing it for the money, I may have overdone that, because I ended up quite impoverished many times.
That's one of the reasons I was on Terrell's couch. But anyway, so Terrell had a bread truck. He had a full-time job and a bread route.
So his bread truck was a team bus on the weekends. So they came by 795 Center Street in East Macon, where the Simmons family lived.
MMA Simmons was a professional cook, so I got real good food that summer. We got in the truck, and I think they may have told me we're playing around Oak.
I didn't know where Round Oak was. Go off about 40 miles away and go through this little town, which is still there.
There's like a post office with some boxes in the general store. That's Round Oak, Georgia. That's it, and then you've got Country.
So we get to this place. It's a cow pasture where the trees cut down, the diamond cut in there. That's the field.
And then the first thing I'm noticing is the cow paddies, and I'm going, OK.
And so because of what I was doing, unlike Jackie Robinson, as I've said in a couple of times in articles, everybody was very nice to me.
They didn't know if I could play or not, but they were going to give me a chance. One guy that wasn't too happy was the guy that was shortstop before I got there, because he got bumped through no fall of his own.
But I had just come out of this experience moving to this place where I got bumped, and I didn't want to give up any playing time. I look back at now.
I don't think I played every inning, but I don't know, maybe he did get to play a little bit. I think I played every inning once I got there.
But he knew I was only going to be there for a while. But everybody else was real friendly. He would sit in the dugout. He would look at me, he didn't say anything.
But he wasn't happy. And I got it. I knew it. And I felt bad for him, but not that bad that I was going to coach a play.
I loved playing baseball, and I loved practicing, but I loved playing in the game. I loved the competition.
So this is my chance to play. I barely got to play. I got injured both years of high school.
I played a lot in American Legion in my junior year, but I didn't, I kept getting hurt, and I kept running into Tom Griffin, who got drafted number four in the country,
and was working pitch here of the year when he was 20 years old, struck out 200 for Houston, who was also a good enough hitter that he pinned shit.
He was six foot four. I wasn't going to beat Tom Griffin out. That just wasn't going to happen.
I had forgotten he was drafted first round number four in the country. That's why I had to beat him.
So I got to play, and as I said in the article, the first ball hit to me, I think it was maybe first or second inning.
Bopped out of my glove, but I made a quick recovery. I had a quick release through it, and I'm pretty sure it was a tie.
A tie goes to the runner. I'm probably going to call him out. He gave me the call. And I think they sensed, you know, here's this new kid.
He's out here by himself. He's working with Dr. King. We're going to, and as a guy there wrote the nice heart of play.
The guy there wrote the nice article for the early week. He said that was sort of a welcome. But I got the call.
That should have been E 11, though. It should have been E 6. It was close, but it was a tie. The tie goes to the runner.
I got the call. And of course that boosted my confidence. Instead of having an error your first play, you made the play.
Because that happens in baseball. Sometimes, I mean, I don't know if the umpire did on purpose. I think you did on purpose.
Because I was the white kid and they were being nice to me because they knew I was there. At bat, it was very interesting because we didn't have any batting practice.
And I had not played in a year. And I was an okay hitter, although I've since Jeff Pentland, who later was sent me social coach and Dodgers coach in many about 16.
He since showed me how to hit, but in those days swing level, keep your eye on the ball. Don't step on the bucket.
So, you know, it was whatever natural ability you had. And I had some, but I told you, I said, Jeff, why don't you tell me this one year in high school?
He said, I didn't know when I went to her high school. I said, I said, you knew you were doing it because he was so good at hitter. He was such a great hitter.
But he learned the mechanics of it. And that's what in major league baseball, the hitting coaches, it's a science. It's a science.
That's why they have videotape and they correct a little hitch in this net.
So, but so I was just winging it. And I was competitive. And I had a bunch out of my stats, which I've, are in theirs.
It was, I was on base 11 out of 15 times, which is very, very good on base average. But there were 11, 10 walks, once in the head, but with a curved ball.
I wasn't tested off like Jaguar. It was a curved ball in Warner Robbins. And it just hit my helmet. We wore helmets by then back in the old days.
And then it sacrificed fly. And I drove in a run to tie a game. And they were very happy that I made that contact.
But the walks, which are very odd, how can somebody get it? And then I struck out three times. But I beat the pitcher in the sense 11 out of 14 times versus walks versus strikeouts.
And most of those at bath, if you know what a 9 or 10 pitch at bat is in baseball, 3, 2 is 5 pitches. And then if you keep fouling off pitches, you, I mean Bryce Harper + Matt Kemp just did this against a good pitcher.
He had 11 pitch at bat, the pitcher opening day, then the giant pitcher had to go out. Linica, I think. And he wore him out.
My timing was off. And I just, I had never done that before in my life. But I kept hitting foul ball after foul ball after foul ball after foul ball. And then I got a walk.
And that happened. I'd say of those 11 walks about 9 were probably more than 8 or 9 pitch were 8 or 9 11. Some were, I mean, there probably one, I think one at bat, I must have had 10 foul balls.
But I wanted to, I wanted to do also wall. My coordination wasn't good enough. My time wasn't because I had any batting practice.
I never got any batting practice because they practiced during the week. I couldn't, I had to do voter registration during the week.
They didn't practice on batting practice on Sunday before the games. I just had to go out and play. And I, but I really, I didn't want to strike out.
So I just, I could get enough of the ball. Then finally my last game in Nilegeville, which is now famous for the quarterback for the, for the, for the terrible incident there in Nilegeville in the bar.
Very ugly incident, which is no longer a fan of a big whatever is nameless. But that's where we played a double hitter there in my last time.
And the Brenner was on third and, and they got the press probably down the middle. And I hit it far enough in center field.
The, I, one of my friends said, oh, you hit it to the wall. I said, night at the wall, but he didn't have to slide. I hit it far enough where he came in standing up, which tied the game, which is always a good feeling.
And when I went back to the bench, I got some nods of approval. So, you know, and I think I made, and I made one other error.
I made an error in one Robins playing at the Air Force page, which was very, to me, very ironic that I go south because I'm trying to do a president game.
And I was trying to do a John F. Kennedy said, and Martin Luther King asked to help my country.
Most of the white people don't like what I'm doing, but the military bases are integrated because they have to be by law since 48, two years after Jackie Robinson, because he integrated in 46 in baseball, 47 in the majors.
It's a very true and integrated, 48 in the military. But Warner Robins, we could plan the field there. And we were playing a team from Warner Robins, somebody reserved it.
We went in through the gates, you know, and they knew we were coming. And no white people came to the game. But there was under the lights. And they were good lights.
The guy hit it just hit a monster, one hot line drive at me at short, and it exploded and went by me. And it was an error. I mean, it was a hard play, but it was an error. And it cost us a run, and I felt real bad.
I mentioned a couple of my players, one whose name I didn't know. And I'm not sure he came to the reunion that I organized in 2002, which is the article from the, that's how the, I met a guy who got me involved with the Georgia Sports Hall of Fame.
He's a former player that lived there, a major leader.
But one of the guys played for the Jackie Robinson Allshar. So I have that connection with Jackie Robinson. One of my teammates on my team. I don't know if he was playing on the team when I was there, but he was on the Macon Bombers also toured with Jackie Robinson.
He may have been there when I was there. I don't know that. But he came to the reunion. He did come to the reunion. I don't know if he played the somewhere I played.
But the other guy was quite amazing. He was a guy named Ralph Eason. He was built like the, not Ken Norton Jr., but Ken Norton Sr., the football player.
He was tall and just built like a tree trunk. And he had never played pro ball. But he was really good. And Ralph hit one in Warner Robins. I haven't been back there. But they didn't have fences.
But they had lights that were out like 300 something left field, 375 and center, whatever. He hit it out of the lights. I mean, he and and turn us around. We won the game. So my erud in cost us the game. So Ralph saved me that game.
So the Empire saved me with the first error and Ralph saved me with the second, which so that was two errors in five games. So I wasn't playing great in the field. But again, I was not practicing too much.
But Ralph, I remember Ralph hit the ball. And I don't know if I'm the only thing I ever found it. I mean, he probably hit it 500 feet. But he hit it. I mean, he was a big and about 6 foot 4. And he was just ripped muscles. I mean, he was a big, strong guy. And he hit it, he hit it perfect.
He just went out out of the lights and disappeared. And we went in the game in Warner Robins. So we won four out of five. The five games I played, one, four out of five.
And when are you making a reunion to think about reunion of the baseball teams? Yeah, we did. And they make and braves. That time was the Mike Dunn, who's now the general manager of the braves team up north of Atlanta. I'm blanking on the name. They got it. They built on the 25th of my $1.000 stadium when they moved from making. They didn't have the irrigation to when it rained. The Michael and the underneath all the major league stadiums.
The drainage, yeah, the drainage and making wouldn't put the money and they should have because they lost their team. That's a minute, pen and teams. But the making braves were in their last year there. Mike Dunn was great. And minorly teams, they always liked promotions. So we had a we had a making bombers night. And it was very interesting because later on I did some I did some clinics there. And the police were there in the military was there. There was a policeman about my age who knew when they when then my friend Jim Goethe who played for Kansas City. Who's a big guy.
And then the city who's a convert to Judaism. It's 5G. He's on radio there. And car tractor like my dad. And so they had the police. And so so we had a ceremony before the clinic, which Jim ran for 25 years. The police were there. And so he said that I had played there for the making bombers. I was only white making bombers.
And so the police had been there for a long time. And so he knew that if I was the only white there, I was probably a civil rights worker. He may have been the guy that arrested me. But you know, they were all very spectral. But we had a moment of contact where we both knew that we had some history. So that was interesting. And that actually that field in Macon Luther Williams field, which was 1919 was one of the third oldest fields. That was used for the Jack Robinson film that just came out. Most of the dugout scenes, which have blue screens behind them because they recreated up a field and they've recreated this film.
But they filmed the train station there and they filmed a number of the, I think the runway shots and maybe even the shower shot, not the dugout shot because that's a recreation of that field. But but they use that field. And Jackie actually played on that field because Brooklyn Dodgers would barbs for a very camp in L.I. have interviewed my book.
What Brooklyn Dodgers would do as a team is when they would come north out of Viral Beach, they would play in Birmingham, Montgomery, Jacksonville. And they would insist it must be after the first year when Jackie was there and they didn't let an integrated audience.
They said, we'll come to your town and do an exhibition. Everybody gets to come. And so it was still segregation. It was before Brown versus Board of Education, things like that. When Brooklyn Dodgers played, black people sat in the stands. And Jackie and Roy, I have a picture of my book of them from Macon that I got from the library, but that same field where the actor played Jackie played, which is kind of neat. And that's maybe one of the reasons they went back there. I don't know. Same with Birmingham.
And you arrested both in Macon and in America? I was. You want to hear those?
Two kind of interesting and one typical of my experience. First one, and I was the only one arrested and Macon. Rev. Eric Schiller, the minister, was the only one beaten up. And that was mainly because William P. Randall had told the town, you want you want you want some, you want Birmingham or you want some business going on in your town.
These white people were coming here. The change is coming. And he had already integrated the buses around the family. He had an understanding with the white business establishment to make it. And they were smart enough and they already had 30% black vote of the Negro voters were registered. So they had some. That's why they sent us there because they knew we could get some. Now we were also being photographed by the white citizens council, who had an office across from from where we were working at the courthouse. So it wasn't as though there were. And the client had a rally at the same park where we had the first integrated July 4th.
So it wasn't as though nothing was going on. But in terms of the town leadership, the police chief and the mayor, they had a choice between Birmingham and terrible publicity and Selma and terrible publicity or trying to keep the lid on and keeping the business community going.
Which the Montgomery business community had done in the mid 50s. So there were people who were smart enough and you know, and not obviously most southerners, I would say even most, well, I don't know most.
There were certainly many, many, many southerners who were not happy with the white citizens council and the clan, but to stand up was to be ostracized by terrorists, the clan were terrorists, that's just what it was.
And the citizens council had a lot of prominent business people besides people that weren't so prominent. So and the politicians were beholden to them for votes and so on.
So, but William P. Randall had done a lot of things and we, he had an agreement with the police chief not to bother us, but apparently didn't get down to all the officers on the street.
So, I did a number of things that were sort of key and I'm saying that Joel Seagal says that Stanford University has sent a team down called Project Self. It's all in Green Library and all the transcripts and the audios, which I've examined.
Joel Seagal, who was our administrative leader, when they'd hit his interview, singled me out as the hardest worker. So, it's in his interview.
So, I was an athlete, I was in better shape probably than anybody and I was extremely dedicated. The humidity really got to us from California.
People were getting tired at three in the afternoon and I said, hey, we've only got 10 weeks, we can't get tired at three in the afternoon, we got to keep going.
And I was the pain in the ass and I was also the youngest except for one other, somebody who was also a freshman.
Diane Hirsch was the radical of our group, she would have rather been with SNCC, but they didn't have a project that SNCC, but Diane was very cool.
But anyway, she became a nurse married his spanner guy and worked for the same union I did, but just after I didn't, I'd been chasing Diane around.
If you ever heard of Diane Hirsch, she's now has a spanner class name I'd love to touch base with her.
She lived with Gloria Wise's family, Gloria in America, Gloria Wise is one of the four women arrested in the movement that pushed the voting rights through to a voting rights bill out of Congress.
They've been trying to stall it during scope, which is why some have happened in March when the Johnson gave a speech about the bill in March, but there were five more months to August.
The reason being, because of scope, the Southern legislators wanted to stall it till we left, then there was no pressure for a strong enforcement clause.
Because we were there and after Americus and when the bill was stalled in the incident report show, we had of the 90 projects we had people in the street in 75 and the White community said, okay enough.
The Southerners were blocked and said, okay, sign the fucking bill. I shouldn't have said that. But the bill got signed, but we had registered people, but in some places they couldn't register anybody.
Many of the counties, they were blocked. And that one of the reasons they sent us to make it is because we could register people.
Americus was almost impossible and they were still arresting black women for standing in a white woman's voting line, which of course was illegal in a year after the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
Yeah, well, you can even get into terror. Terror was so bad. I mean, literally, I heard stories that we tried to move out from the Sumter to other places and they were already in Albany.
There was a car that went into terror and it was shot. So many bullets at it, it turned around and came back.
Terror was one of the most terrible terror, one of the most notorious. I don't know what Charles was around. And Albany thought of terror in 65.
The story I heard was we tried to go there. We got shot at. There were so many bullets at the county line. They were waiting. We turned around and the people wanted to go.
I got thrown out of there in 61. So that's a long history of trying and not thinking about it.
So anyway, I had started. We didn't. We first tried to go in the communities. The people would say yes, not be there. And we were wasting a lot of money.
We were missing three out of four. We wouldn't would tell us because we were white. What we wanted to hear like they did with most white people.
And then they wouldn't be there because they were afraid to go downtown. Even America. Even as good as I mean, making even as good as it wasn't making, the fear level was still very high because people could get fired.
They might be able to register, but then they lose their job. So I then on a Saturday had a church bus or on one day wasn't a Saturday because we couldn't have registered on a Saturday.
Maybe on a Friday. I had a church bus and I brought down 12 people. While they were in registering, people were walking by the courthouse and I just said, hey, would you like to work with Dr. King? You can come register right now.
And I got seven more in 20 minutes. I went back until Joel's thinking, hey, we can get them downtown. They might be too dangerous. We don't have much choice.
We just spent $200 in gas in the last couple of weeks and we've only got 44. We got to start making some numbers. And so we decided to give it a try.
So and then once we did that and then that's when the clan started, the right systems cows started photographing us. The city also gave us two pardon spaces.
But we also moved down to the bars on Broadway, which is now Martin Luther King Drive, which is where the Georgia Sports Hall of Fame is, right? Right near where I got arrested.
So we went down to Broadway to get the people out of the bars in the pool halls and Ken Long, who was my roommate, who was in Northern California, parked his old, old mobile there. I think no Joe Gomercat and Olsen, Ken Long had a Ford, I think.
And he was in a waiting zone, but he was in a waiting zone for about half hour because we were soliciting the bars. Well, the police came and they didn't give him a chance to move. They started kind of saying stuff and they were, they wrote a maticot.
And they weren't very nice. I've been, when in the barbershop, we were then trained by John Doran William P. Randall. If you're having trouble with the police, call and let us know what's going on. In case you get taken away or whatever.
Apparently, and this is honest truth, somebody said something. I don't know who was it made a cross, Martella comment of some kind. That's what they said. It was not me. I'm looking in the camera. I wasn't me. I just went in the barbershop and got on the phone. Apparently the police officer thought it was me that I had said something. I don't know why I thought that, but at least that was his story. I think he really did think it was me.
So I went in the barbershop and I've got Doranl on the phone and I said Bill, or maybe it was Joel. I think it was Bill. Actually, I'm not sure it was somebody. It was somebody at the office. I don't know if it was William P. Randall or Joel.
Joel mostly stayed in the office. And I said, you know, we're getting a rast here down in Broadway and I said, oh, the policeman's coming in the barbershop. I think they're going to be arresting me.
I had to hang up. And the fact that it actually took me in the car, arrested me and put me in the back seat, started driving.
Again, we then had to go down to whatever the street is, turning rights towards the jail, turning left out to the country.
I just read these reports of the rest people taking them on the country and they'd beat the crap on them.
That's when I was nervous, which way are they going to turn? I didn't mind going to jail. Our office was right across the people in the jail.
I had no doubt William P. Randall was going to take care of me. But I did not want to go the other way.
So I was nervous. And then the two policemen are in the front and I said, what am I being arrested for? I was on the phone in the barbershop.
And so the police officer said, I'm quoting them because I don't like to use the N word. He said, you're a nigger lover and you're a smart alloc.
And I said under my breath, I didn't know that was against the law. And he said, what? And I said, no, that's why I turned right.
So that was the only conversation I really remember. And that was, I don't know what the charge was, but that was the only charge I heard.
Then I was a quote lover and a smart alloc. That's why I think you really thought that I had said something.
So I got into jail and I wasn't in the jail more than I got booked. I was in, you know, putting me behind bars.
I wasn't behind bars more than 10 minutes. And I was out. William P. Randall got me out. Not only that. And then actually Fred Hoffman who did the film,
which I can give you a DVD over called Be Somebody. But he threw away all the stuff he didn't use. Why? I don't know. But he was 16 millimeters.
He had hours and hours of footage, which we could have done a full length movie on. But he actually photographed me coming out of the jail across to William P. Randall's office.
Incidentally, our office later became taken over by Phil Walden + Capricorn Records, which was the The Allman Brothers, The Allman Brothers, and from Macon.
And Little Richard is from nearby and Otis Redding is from Macon. So Phil Walden + Phil Walden + Capricorn Records started Phil Walden + Capricorn Records.
And our office was above liquor store and eventually that entire block became Phil Walden + Capricorn Records, which is now abandoned and should be a museum, really.
But it's also the scope office. And the famous little diner called H&H Restaurant was where The Allman Brothers were.
All the integrated band members, Otis Redding went there. That's still down the street. That was between William P. Randall's,
Macon Weekly newspaper office, and our office, which then became Phil Walden + Capricorn Records.
So big historic blocks in Macon, Georgia, in the music industry, which is a big thing in Macon. They had the music hall of fame that they moved it there.
It was a great music hall of fame. They lost funding and the budget stuff. But anyway. So then they get me out and I go into Bill's office,
and Bill calls up the sheriff or the police chief. And Bill, when he got excited, kind of talked to him, he said, Chief, Chief, what are your officers doing resting this young man from UCLA?
I thought you understood that we weren't going to put up with any of this stuff. The year officers knew that. And so then they didn't say anything.
And he barked at the sheriff a couple of times, because Bill had had a confrontation over the buses about two years earlier.
William P. Randall was Dr. King's friend, Hosea's friend. He ran a newspaper called the Macon Weekly. He had a construction company.
He was worked with Hosea Williams and something called the Georgia Voters League, if ever to the Georgia Voters League. That was a network they had all around.
Georgia, probably other states. He was also involved with the NAACP. He was the local leader. Now there was a more left-leaning local leader who also had a newspaper.
But Bill was the one who worked with Hosea Williams and Dr. King. There was a little rivalry between Bill and this other guy, but Fred, who was more leftist than the rest of the time,
was the older and a Air Force veteran. He kind of liked the more radical guy. But Bill was the guy. And Bill was the mainstream guy. That's why he went into politics and a citizen politics. And a wonderful guy.
And so then he turned to me and he said, well will he? The police chief would like to drop the charges if it's all right with you. And I said, well, I don't know Bill. What do you think?
He said, I think the police chief has told me that all of his officers are going to understand that they can't harass you all anymore.
I think you should let him drop the charges. I'm still not sure what the charges were. At that point, I don't think I knew actually what the official charge was.
I don't think to this day I don't know. I should probably go back to see if those records are available. It may have been disturbing the peace. I don't really know. Well, I heard that it was quite eloquent. That's the only thing I was told.
So I said, okay. So then Bill barked at the police chief a few more times, which made a big impression on me, by the way, that he was telling the police chiefs off and the police chief wanted to apologize.
And I, of course, spread that around. And I think the police chief spread it around with his officers. I don't think we had any more problems. Nobody else got arrested.
And I was kind of the test case. It didn't work out good for the police officers. I don't know what happened to that guy. But I'd say he may have been the guy I met at the Lutheran Phil many years later. I don't know.
I think they all knew about it, though. I think they all knew about it. I'm sure they all knew about it because police chief knew about it.
I think they made sure they knew about it. And no one else got arrested. And we worked downtown from then on.
And one of the things that happened was there was a guy named Denny Lee now, whose niece later had a official position with Habitat in America.
And Denny ended up in the Peace Corps for a long time and working out a country for a long time. And I've been in touch with him just briefly.
I'd like to hear from him then and then I'd school in the Midwest. And some other people, they had a guy came up and did overalls with a gun or the 38 or some gun.
I don't know what caliber. And not to me, but in on the corner where we were trying to get voters and he took the gun out, stuck it in his face.
And he said, if you're in this corner and now I'm going to come back to kill you. Well, that didn't work.
We stayed on the corners of the guy didn't come back and kill us. But I mean those kinds of things were going on in Macon, which was better than Americus where they didn't come up to you.
They just shot at you. They didn't give you any warning. Later, the story was when I went back to Macon, there was a warning that if you're in town on 24 hours you're dead.
And it sounded serious enough that it made me uncomfortable. But of course, at 18, I wasn't going to leave then. Bill said, no, you're going to leave.
Here, time for you to go. And I was planning to leave anyway. But that's, I wrote that in something I sent you. But in America, so that was my arrest there.
Well, then the other time William C. Randall, who I told you about, William P. Randall's nephew, very involved, was almost 16.
Had his learners permit. But then, or was 16, had a learner spent the no license. His dad is uncle had been too busy. And his dad, I don't know if you know his dad situation was.
But of course, when you're 16, you like to drive and impress the girls, which I knew because I was only 18. I had been 16 years too earlier and wanted to drive to impress the girls.
So we were on our way home one day from downtown and William wanted me to let him drive. And he had the learner's permit, but it expired. He didn't have a license.
So we got three blocks and the girls from pretty girls were in the car, black girls. And I knew why he wanted. I was sympathetic. It was a male bonding thing. And I let him drive.
Well, I was driving Ken's car that didn't have power steering. He knew how to drive. And he had driven his uncle Bill's car that had power steering that he could just swing around.
Well, they got to this corner and he tried to do the swing around like he did with one finger. The wheeled and swing. And we started into somebody's yard. Then because it was an inexperienced driver, he got panicky. And he tried to hit the brake, but he hit the gas instead and rammed into a park car in a black man's yard.
Who wasn't too happy when he came out and he wasn't too confused about me because most people knew that the white people were there, but he wasn't happy about somebody just rammed into his car.
Of course, I don't think that made a real good impression. There wasn't an impression that William C wanted to make on the two black girls.
I had done something similar almost crashing my mom's car. So I sympathized with the whole thing. The black man was unhappy enough. He called the cops. And then William C had a knife in his pocket, which I didn't know.
So they arrested him for the knife. And I think the driving and they arrested me. Now they probably could have given us a ticket, but they didn't, but they didn't want to mean about it. I mean, we were obviously guilty. And I was obviously guilty of letting a minor without a license drive.
And so they took us in and we paid a $60.5 fine went to court. My dad sent them money. He wasn't thrilled about that. But of all the things were happening. That was the least of his worries.
I think I had to work it off when I got back some way to do some painting for him. And so that was my second arrest and making... I don't know how I get in these situations. I just seem to get it.
America is a little more dramatic. America has started telling the story about Jamo. So we got called down there.
Actually quite interesting introduction to America. We went down at night. It was the night after Andrew Whatley had been killed.
Four women were in jail. Dick Gregory was in town, leading marches. Hosea Williams had started night marches.
Vivid memory of the first night in a church. There was two young African-American guys with rifle at each doors. We slept in the pews about 40 of us.
What Hosea Williams wanted to do was bring in scope workers from all the projects around Georgia and Alabama. South Carolina was a little too far.
And show us what a hot movement was like. Also we needed more troops for the marches because once the women were arrested and then the white guy was killed.
Piggly when the white kid, man, Andrew always killed. The state patrol came. 100 state patrolmen were there. The clan had a rally. There were a lot of shootings going on.
I mean, you know, at people, no one else got hit. And so Hosea Williams wanted troops. This was going to be the Selma of the summer. And that's actually what he said in the New York Times and LA Times articles are in my book.
And so we were the reinforcements. And so that night there was a burned out car across the street that had been firebomb. So it was a lot different than making.
And it was kind of in the battle and essentially in the battle from the back lines to the front line.
And you find with this term, hot movement. Huh?
I don't know what Hosea Williams called. I know what the way Hosea Williams described it. I think he was able to say I want you to see what a real movement is like. I think those were the, but, but a movement where the media was there, where there was mass demonstrations, where the opposition was making it life or death in some degree, which meant then that the movement was going to be a real movement.
And that then that the media would portray it. The whole thing of nonviolence is to dramatize in a creative way. That's what Dr. King said in the letter from (the) Birmingham jail.
And create, do a creative tension nonviolently that will dramatize the injustice that will expose the racism and the injustice, which is what the whole movement was about from the Montgomery Best Boycott on, where you had the media come because of violence.
And compared the entire number of people that were killed in the movement from the beginning of the Montgomery Best Boycott till 1968, the end of your period, which I think is a good period.
It's less than one day in Syria or in Egypt, where they've had the Arab Spring and Barack Obama went and said model the civil rights movement, but apparently they don't have the foundation. Unfortunately, and we did have the Judeo Christian foundation here.
I'm not a scholar enough about Islam. I know there are many peaceful things in Islam, but that part of Barack Obama speech, which by the way, some of the Jewish community, because I know people in the Republican Jewish Commission committee, thought that Barack Obama was being anti-Israel by saying that in Cairo, Georgia when he talked to the Egyptians at the beginning of his trip, what he was telling them is used nonviolence, which they tried and have done somewhat successfully.
But the governmental structure has not supported it. We at least had a governmental structure in the United States that was based enough on law, even with the flaws in the federal government that's Nick's talk about in the corrupt federal judges of which there were some, which the Kennedy administration acknowledges they made a mistake.
They were lied to. I've talked to Burke Marshall. Those judges came up from Georgia and Mississippi and said, we promise you, Robert F. Kennedy called him in. And he said, if you're going to do this, you've got to follow federal law. And those judges looked him in the eye and lied to him. And they were made mistakes. There was some guy in South Georgia.
They shouldn't keep getting beat up over it. It was a tough situation. I wish Nick would forgive that and understand that better and not feel so hurt about it. Same with this quote from, I know I'm getting off topic, but I want to say this, that David Giro used and said that John F. Kennedy called Nick Sunsabitches when the two guys from Birmingham, three guys came up. The transcripts are in that book. What happened in that meeting was they tried to tell Kennedy these three businessmen.
Get King out of there. Get King out of there. He's causing trouble. Kennedy told them many times. And it's on tape. It's a civil rights tape at the Kennedy Library. There's a whole series to identify in my book, place in Clark. Giro misrepresent it in Frank Smith Jr, who was the African American Civil War Museum, knew the quote.
Nick is still angry about the quote, John F. Kennedy is a himicrant. He called us Sunsabitches. He was complimenting him. He said, your tough Sunsabitches. What happened was seven times the white men from Birmingham said, get King out. And he told him we didn't put King in there. We can't get him out. And by the way, King ate the problem men from Birmingham didn't say evidently.
You're the problem. Your laws are the problem. Change your laws. Hire some black people in your stores. And then the guy from Birmingham said, we can't have black people waiting on white people. And he said, come on. He said the military. That was difficult in 1948. People had to live in barracks together and shower together. He said hiring people in stores. And you can listen to him. He was magnificent. He said, that's nothing. That's the problem. King isn't the problem. You're the problem. And of course they negotiated that problem out.
And they did hire black people. And then finally, after they said seven times, get King out. He said, look, you ought to be happy. It's King and not Snick. He said, they're tough. That John R. Lewis. Their Sunsabitches, they're tough. You don't want them. You better take King. Which is exactly by the way what Malcolm X said. You better take Dr. King and not me.
Dr. John Kennedy described it the same way Malcolm X described it. But David Garrow took it out of context. And it was circulated through academia. Snick knows that quote. They're hurt by it. And I want Andy to talk about it. And he said, Dr. King talked about healing the sick. I want to heal Snick's pain until them John Kennedy who loved toughness.
This is a tough guy who talked about Macho 50 mile hike. He said, I told Frank Smith Jr, he said, you were tougher than Dr. King. Frank and President, he said, yes, we were tougher than Dr. King.
Excuse me Frank. I hope you see this. You weren't tougher than Dr. King. Nobody was tougher than Dr. King. But you were tough. And that's what John F. Kennedy said. He was complimenting you. So to get back to my next arrest. So we were down there. They needed volunteers. Every time there was a mass meeting, they asked for volunteers. I kept raising my hand pretty soon.
They knew who I was. Instead of one of 60 or 80 new white people, I was the kid that kept raising his hand and kept taking assignments. Well, as it happened, Andrew Whatley had just been killed before we got there. His funeral was that Saturday at the Methodist Church.
Or maybe it was the Baptist. There was two prominent churches where the mayor and the fire chiefs and the police right across the street from each other in the same block.
And they needed two whites to go to tell the media that were there covering it, that there was a press conference coming up. So Rev. Eric Schiller, who was from UCLA, the minister, Rev. Eric Schiller.
And we went. Now if they would have known who we were, the white people, they would have been very unhappy. We were there. But there were other people. We were in suits.
And my one suit, my dad bought me its ears for 25 dollars for my high school prong. And my way, my dad said he was proud of me when I called my dad and told him I was going. It was the first time in my life.
He said, no, I told you more. I said, well, he wasn't happy. I wanted me to be a musician out of baseball player. But when I called him after I decided I was very mature enough to say, I'm not going to ask my parents because if I get killed, they'll feel guilty.
More guilty than if I tell them I've already decided and I was 18 people were going to Vietnam. And I told him, this is what I'm going to do. The line went silent. And he said, I'm proud of you. Those were the first words out of his mouth because of his feeling not humor.
He said, I'm not humored for all those things. So anyway, so they needed somebody to go to the church. Eric and I went, we took that assignment. Then they needed somebody to go to the John R. Lewis the next day to try and integrate the Baptist church and went up.
Okay, you, you're going with John R. Lewis, the private me with one of the generals. I always think of it as Dr. King was the joint chief of staff general, Hosea Williams was a general, John R. Lewis was a general, Abernathy was a general, Andy was a general, Dr. King was chairman of the joint chief of staff in the movement.
That's kind of how Jim Colony honey said it out and his thing. So the interesting thing was John and I go up there and John, of course, this is one of many, many, many, many, many.
At a few more, many exponentially, the John R. Lewis have been involved. My first time on camera is a movement person other than the citizens council. They, they had me on camera.
But so we go up there. I'm essentially an extra John was the star and I'm the extra with John and he goes up there and fire chief Henderson comes out. I think it was it was the Baptist church and he has a tape recorder because he wants to record and so nobody's misquoting him to find with us.
So he says we don't want you here. We don't want you here. And that's we got actually footage of that on CBS news. And John R. Lewis says, well, but I'm a Baptist and this is a Baptist church. We'd like to worship here. I'd like to worship here.
Now we don't watch. He said what about him pointing to me. We don't want him either. And he's with you. We don't want. And he said, but he said, but doesn't, doesn't Jesus say that in Christ, all men are equal. We start quoting the scripture.
He starts quoting Jesus Christ because John's been to some done is what's not a minister because he dropped out of seminary just before he graduated, but he had been the seminary. So he knew scripture started quoting scripture to fire chief Henderson. Fire just Henderson got very flustered.
That doesn't matter here. That doesn't matter here. It's just a chapel. Rest these people. Rest these people. So that fire chief Henderson was was quite unable to answer John R. Lewis when he started quoting scripture. He couldn't figure out a good answer as to why Jesus was went on us in the church.
So fire chief Henderson came and we left. We didn't get arrested, but I think I don't know if we said we'll be back, but we came back. So that was one of the big deals. And that was on national news and some of my baseball friends saw me. They've got back and they're like, well, I didn't sell you on national news.
And that was on all the national, all the three networks night. It was a big story. That's where all the media was. Once Andrew Whatley had been killed. There were media there anyway. But once there was a killing, of course, the media wanted to see if they're going to be more killing whatever.
They were doing a great job. Tom Brokall was there did a great job. I mean, the media did was doing great work in those days. I shouldn't have said it in that way, but obviously that brings, you know, it's not the planes that land that bring the media. It's the ones that don't land.
So we were then working. I got shot at that week at close range twice. And then we went back to the church the next week. That week, John took his group to the Baptist church.
And Willie Bolden took a group to the Methodist church. I don't think anybody, I don't know, somebody may have gone to the Methodist church that first week too. I don't know. I was at the Baptist church with John.
And that photo actually ended up in Ebony magazine eight months later. They did a special article about the movement and Christianity. And they talked about the Americus churches.
And that was part of Hosea Williams's plan. Hosea Williams said the media is here. We're going to dramatize the churches. And nobody from the white community could have said that was unfair.
Or today could say it because Lena Turner, who had been a snake worker who later worked with scope. Because at that point, a number of people in snake also worked and were paid by a CLC. Lena Turner was one of them. She was also one of the women arrested.
She went after the 64 Civil Rights Act of 1964 to every white church in town, every church in Americus letter in except the first Baptist and the first Methodist or the big important people work.
So we knew who those two, they knew and the local people told Hosea Williams that. So that was part of the plan. We're going to expose this unchristinlike behavior.
The difference at the Methodist church is their national body had passed an edict saying no one could be refused. I'm not sure that Lena knew that at the time or let them know.
But the next week, I was a
Turner. I believe Lena. Lena is still alive in Detroit last I heard. I tried to contact her and she did not come down for the
American Sumter County Movement. They have an organization which is very active. Samohoan is the co-chair. Gloria Wise, who was one of the other women arrested, is deceased but her sister Jewel unfortunately had a stroke as a dear friend, is involved with that.
Amy Peacamble was one of the other women arrested there listed in my book in the articles. She's still alive. But that's why I think it's be great if you talk to Samohoan. That's a very active organization that is not embedded and are teaching their history.
I think Sumter County more than any county, more than Albany, more than Lowndes County, Alabama because of Coenania and because of being the founding place of Habitat.
And also Andersonville National Historic Site is there, the Civil War Cemetery. So it's an amazing history from the Civil War up through the movement. And the legacy is also Habitat, which is part of Coenania, which is very positive.
And unfortunately some of the other legacies are not so positive.
But America says a glorious story. But I'm in Sumter County. So anyway, so as we're going up to the Methodist Church, Willie Bowling is leading the group because he's one of Dr. King's lieutenants, one of his A's lieutenants.
Now Rev. Willie Bolden, not at the time, it wasn't Rev. Willie Bolden. And he said, Willie, he said to me, I can't get arrested today. I'm leading the movement here. You lead the group. Why he picked me? I mean, I'd only been around for 10 days of the people there.
I guess I had been volunteering more. So I then led that group to the Methodist Church. And we were told, you can't come in. They met us in the line and some of them had plaque jacks.
And they said, you can't worship here. And I said, can we, and I think either he told me or I knew that, I don't know how it was. But I think we knew we wanted to say a prayer if we couldn't go.
So I said, can we say a prayer? And they said, yes, before we were arrested. And you say, you're the group of most of these LA students, Chuck Ham, any lanes, Fonken, all of us that were on this telegram that Richard "Rick" Tuttle had sent.
And I read the picture that was on every front page in LA Times, LA, general constitution, New York Times. They shot the picture from across the street. And so I'm in the front. So I'm barely seeing you can barely see me.
And I do have the news footage of it, though, which is kind of interesting to watch. And so also interesting to listen to this Stanford interview where I'm much less hyper than I think I came back with post-traumatic stress.
And it had been more hyper ever since than I ever was before. And I thought I wasn't hyper before. But anyway, so I, we now said the prayer and then they arrested us, took us to jail. And then John R. Lewis had another interesting moment. We get in the jail with Sheriff Fred B. Chappell.
And he said, okay, what's over here? They would, the polite term in those days was NIGRA's. And of course, the joke in the movement was, the white people said, well, that's our southern accent. We can't say need grow.
Because we don't say grow. We say grrr. We say NIGRA. We're not being rude. And so what black people would say, those white people can say need. And they can say grow. So they can say NIGRA.
And so, but, but Sheriff Fred B. Chappell said NIGRA. And that was probably better than he said most of the time, frankly.
This is who Jimmy Carter had said was my dear friend. Because Jimmy Carter had a lot of dear friends down there because he was from planes. The man that beat Bill Rao next to David Bell, whose family I stayed with, was the former state rep who served with Jimmy Carter.
Jimmy by the way stayed neutral, which is not the worst thing in the world. He ordered both the clan and the movement and the reporters, which is written about by the AJC guy in his book, the one that pulls her prize, office property.
What Florence Jordan told me was that Jimmy knew that he couldn't stay in business if he took sides. I mean, if he showed any sympathy, he wasn't going to have a peanut business. And he had kids and everything else. So he did his missionary work, which he did do at the time outside of planes.
But he did tell the clan came and wanted him to join. He said, get off my property. I'm not joining. He was a Navy veteran. And the New York Times came and he said, get off my property. Not talking to you.
And anyway, but, but, but the guy that served with him was the one who beat Bill Rao. It would have been the death, but David fell on top of him. But anyway.
So what happened in the jail? So Sheriff Fred B. Chappell said, niggas over here, what people over here? And John said, well, that's a violation of the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
In 64, you can't segregate us in the jail. You can't do that. And Sheriff Fred B. Chappell said, well, you may run the streets, but you don't run this jail. And John said, well, I don't run this. He said, yes, you do, but you don't run this jail. Get over there.
And so they segregated us in the jail, which of course gave John a chance to talk to the two guys that have been arrested for shooting Andrew Whatley.
He claimed what's innocent. They eventually went to prison. I don't know what the details were as far as what actually happened. But the shooting was in retaliation for a lot of violence directed towards the marchers.
And that night, those guys said enough, we're not going to have our people. They were throwing broken glass at kids. And it was not, and they were shooting at people.
I don't know one of the other nice things that was happening in America was as they released people not from the county jail, but the city jail, which was downtown. I was in the county jail.
Fire station was across the street. And the firemen had hunting slingshots and ball bearings. And they were shooting the slingshots, which could have killed somebody, put their eye out.
They may have been good enough shots that they weren't hitting people, but they were ricocheting off as they knew when they were being released and they were shooting.
The other story in there that's amazing is Warren Fortson, who was Jimmy Carter's lawyer, who came out for a biracial council, which the whites wouldn't agree to in the beginning, was actually run out of town. He was a white guy.
And his brother was Ben W. Fortson Jr, the sitting secretary of state. And to me, that really showed how bad the repression was. If the brother of the sitting secretary of state in Atlanta, 150 miles away, could not be protected.
I mean, this is the brother of the secretary of state, who knows the governor, who was the liberal cross-enders, and can't mobilize his tape patrol that he doesn't, he feels he has to leave for his own safety.
It's pretty dangerous. And that article is in my book and he left Warren Fortson left. But they did create a biracial council within about two weeks.
After those demonstrations, there was a biracial council because the white leaders were getting terrible publicity and they knew that they were going to lose.
So the other guy I would like to mention is a guy named Albert "Red" Heffner. Have you ever heard of Albert "Red" Heffner?
Albert "Red" Heffner was then working for the community of relation service. I also met Jack Nelson of the LA Times down there. But America was where I got to meet, kind of where I proved myself in that all you could say.
And where I met a lot of really substantial, interesting people because of what was happening there. Albert "Red" Heffner was running out of the hot ink harder, the third, the one that worked for Jimmy Carter wrote a book called So the Heffners Left McComb.
The interesting story was Albert "Red" Heffner's eldest daughter was Miss Mississippi in the Miss USA page. Miss America page, the main pageant.
And she was what Virginia Durr called. Virginia Durr's autobiography is called Virginia Durr. If you know much about Virginia Durr, you should read her.
I got to meet her once she was quite elderly. But the magic circle, you know what the magic circle was. Magic Circle for white woman was, Virginia said,
Zer said, as long as white women in the South stayed inside the magic circle, they were catered to. They were taken care of. They were unapetrable. And of course they couldn't be defiled by any black men.
Of course, well, one of the excuses was, you want them to marry your sister or whatever, you know. But so they were put on a pedestal. It was a great story from Selma. There was actually an interracial couple in Selma.
The daughter was from a prominent family. So prominent that the whites couldn't retaliate against the black guy. It was still there by 65. You know how they handled that problem? The family just decided she was no longer white.
That's all the problem. She was no longer white. So there was no longer a problem. And the town, all the white people were, was she not white.
That's how you, because she was, she was too prominent to kill. And the black guy was too prominent to kill. You couldn't do it because they were two. They were one of the town leaders. So how do you solve that problem and sell my Alabama? She ceases to be white.
And this is absolutely true. You can, I forget the guy's name, but that's a great story from Selma. So the South was so conflicted with all this. Another story that's so interesting is that. So anyway, so in Janet Merritt was a woman who was a state rep after the gang.
She was a state rep after the guy who was beating people up. She stepped Virginia Durr. She later got defeated, but she was in for three terms. Another one of five, one of her, was a great artist. I got one of her. I got to meet all these wonderful people.
But anyway, so Albert "Red" Heffner was down there. And he had to leave McComb, Mississippi because all he did is have some blacks and whites at his house to discuss the problem. He was an insurance man. They poisoned his dog, they threatened his family. And he left and he got taken in by the community relation service run by LeRoy Collins, former governor of Florida, who Andrew Young was a friend of, and he was down there.
And I got to know him and a very, you know, press of guy. And he was now working for the Department of Justice. So he, and, and, you know, and of course the younger daughter who wasn't Miss Mississippi kind of got it that the family had to leave. The one that was Miss Mississippi. Why don't I have to leave my friends? I'm Miss Mississippi. I don't want to leave my, you know, I mean, she was on the pedestal. Virginia Durga Virginia Durr when she worked with Eleanor Roosevelt in the New Deal.
Wonderful lady. So I and all same with Foreign Student and in the Clarence Student out of Quentin. So, so we were, we got put in there with about three of the white guys that had been throwing broken glass at black kids and one civil rights worker. And they were having a card game when they finished the card game, they were going to beat him up. Then six of us came in so that that part was over. They didn't, they weren't going to beat him up. But they, they really were one of their, I was a number of times where I had the question on balance.
One was when Jetson Ford put his gun in the belt when we were going out to get the people out in the county areas of Sumter County, which I was actually happy about because I was, I'd already been shot at. So, but I was still a conflict. This is not what Dr. King would really approve of.
To the matter, we're not in a demonstration. The other time was listening to these white guys and it was ugly. It was similar sort of to the Ben Chapman character that was a true character in the Jackie Robinson with the manager of the Phillies who was the worst antagonist.
The worst antagonist and the worst in the language. And I literally, I think I had to put my hands over my ears and, and it was making me sick where I wanted to beat the crap out of these guys, which was against the rules.
And they were literally trying to provoke people? No, no. They were just, that's just who they were. They were just talking about us and they were talking about black people. And that's just how they talked. They were not nice people. They were not of the higher classes, let's say.
And so, but I, you know, I had they started a fight. I could have defended, but I couldn't go attack them. That would have been against what I had pledged myself to nonviolence.
But it made me very, very angry. I mean, I did, I, I want to, and it probably connected emotionally to the, to hear in Kaikwondo. I was like, I didn't think of it at the time, but it was very deep connection.
And I just wanted to shut up. You know, I, I think, but nonviolence was you, you ignored them. You turned the other cheek. And by the time I left, that was, I was pretty much said, you know, many of us could practice it. We could not be a doctor king could live it.
Hosea Williams was not a nonviolent guy. It's one reason Stink doesn't like him so much because he got in their face. You know, he got very angry at people. He, he had a temper. He didn't put up with stuff.
But he practiced nonviolence during the movement and in demonstrations. He walked across the bridge into the end of the battle. I found out by the summer, I could not practice. I could not be spiritually a nonviolent person. Maybe too much football. Maybe Kaikwondo was young, maybe too angry. In my core, I, I had enough abuse. I hadn't, I didn't want to take it anymore. And I also had post-traumatic stress at that point from the shootings and the stress of being scared every day.
I mean, if you're scared, you know, if you have the fight or flight syndrome and you can't do either, you internalize and that's not very good for you. And plus getting, I got shot at from six feet away. I got, you know, from the next car, which told us, told us, told us, scared me.
Is that while you were trying to write a servo? No, that was when I was trying to organize a major in this, which was going to be a great opening scene in my movie after the movie helped.
But ironically, amazingly, really, I'm an Americus. Who'd I run into? A guy from Grant High School name Rich Adler, who was, I was a sports center. He was in the Hall of Fame as a gymnast. He was a ring guy.
Like most gymnasts, small and very muscular because they have to low weight, you know, in their bottom. So a lot of little guys with big arms.
Rich was about five seven, dark hair Jewish, and he had joined SNCC somewhere in other. I don't know if you want to, I don't know where we want it. What's a college? But somehow he's gotten involved with SNCC. He's down there. And in between the week going to churches, I run into Rich. Hey Rich, how you doing?
You haven't seen him in a year because I've been a college. Maybe I'm trying to think if he was a, I think he was a year ahead of me. Maybe not him. He was either in my classroom or your head of me.
But I knew him and he was a good athlete and a lot of the athletes knew each other. We didn't run in the same group. But I know he was in the Hall of Fame because I wrote about him. And I don't know if it was my junior year or my senior year. But he was a real good gymnast. He was all the, all the gymnasts.
And he had been beaten. He's in the news accounts in my book. He had been surrounded by group of whites and beaten up and broken through.
He was a strong guy. And he was also in theory, pledged non-violence. But he wasn't going to beat, you know, 10 guys were going to beat him up. So he broke through the crowd and got away. But they did beating.
And it was in the paper he got injured, whatever. But he came to me and he said, hey, I'm organizing in May Junin. These may is working 80 hours for $20 a week. Let's organize a May Junin.
Well, that didn't come from Hosea Williams. You know, Hosea Williams was doing the churches and the marches. But I thought, yeah, that sounds like a good idea. The little did I know.
Well, the other unfortunate thing was Fred Hoffman, the guy who made the movie Be Somebody, who was an Air Force veteran who was 29. His car was there. He had a Citroen.
I'd probably like a 1963 Citroen. Let me tell you, I don't think there were any other Citroens in the state of Georgia. There certainly was no other Citroens.
I think you may have had Georgia plates on by that time, but it didn't matter. There were no Citroens in America. And all the white people knew that if there was a Citroen, it must be an outsider.
And that was the car I had. I had Fred's car. Not good thinking on my 18 year. I think I was probably wearing my number 10 jersey and driving a Citroen, going to try and organize a May Junin.
That was a third strike. That was not good. But risk condensed. So I just, you know, I didn't think about it very clearly. There was so much going on that, hey, we're on the origin. Okay, good. All right. What are we? What are you doing?
He said, well, we got to go around and pick up the mage and take him to a meeting at the Freedom Center. Freedom Center is... There's the Freedom Center.
That was a little building owned by Barnum's family, the owned Barnum's Funer Home, which was one of the other centers of the movement there whose family had gone to jail.
The wealthy family. You know, the barbers could head into pennant clients. They could... They were independent. The funeral people and the ministers. Everybody else was beholden to the white community, including the teachers and those segregated days.
So we went around to a couple of places. They said no. The women went... They were... They seemed fearful. One of the few times I really saw people fearful.
And this was again, this was the week that Andrew Whatley had been killed. State Patrol had been sent there. The planet had a rally.
Lustromatics was in town. It was a pretty busy week in Americus Georgia. And then I've got some of the news footage from that.
But the mage wouldn't get in the car with two white boys. I think the other thing was that we're not getting in the car with you two white boys because they ain't going to go over big with the white community.
And they may hate you more than us, but they may miss you and hit us when they shoot at you. So they wouldn't come in the car.
So I remember very vividly. And in those days, in most of the black communities, there was not a ghetto. It wasn't even so much the other side of the tracks.
In the least the communities where I was, the black neighborhoods were scattered throughout the downtown here.
The fancy white neighborhood could be a little black poor neighborhood here, little black poor neighborhood. You know, there were pockets, two or three maybe.
So we had to drive through the white from a black neighborhood through white downtown or to another black neighborhood.
And as we came out from the last group that we were talking, we couldn't get anybody to come. We gave up at that point.
I noticed there was a pick. I think I may have noticed the pickup truck on the way in, but I definitely noticed it on the way out.
And as we left it followed. And I noticed because things were going on. I mean, you know, I, that was the first time I got shot at. But, you know, it was a dangerous time.
So I, I noticed there had been bricks. The guy I was living with at David Bell's family, Bill Raul had 13 stitches in his chin. They had driven by and throwing a brick at him, hitting with a brick, then chasing him and beating him with sticks.
And he had also broken some fingers and then David through David was 17 later in the military. He's in Albany, he's a social worker now David Bell. You might try and find David.
And I'd stayed in touch with his mom for years. And I think David may be divorced now with three kids. But he was stationed at Fort Benning for many years. He was a, you know, in the military for 20 years.
Ironically, Bill Raul's brother was a, a chaplain in the military for Benning when Bill went missing my only contact with the FBI that summer. I have a file now from the thread and making at the gas station.
Was I called the Albany, the Albany office. Bill, we were always told to keep tabs. If somebody, if you're going out, tell people when you're coming back. And if you're not back, then try and find out what happened.
So Bill was gone. You know, he had beaten beaten up. And I didn't, he was missing essentially six hours late. So I called the FBI field office in Albany. And I, and I got one of the ones that Dr. King criticized for being a southern who wasn't similar to that, that it was a movement. And it was, oh yeah. He said, you call us back if you find the body.
Click. That was how much they were interested in helping. That was not the case of the FBI agents sent after John Doar got the complaint that I made to Joel Siegel that Joel Siegel sent to him. That's in that book.
You can read their interviews of the people they chased are all over Georgia who had made the threats and you're comming their communication with power service stations, which convinced power service station.
It's not a good enough excuse to say that you're hiring people that aren't taking down the white only signs. You better take down the white only signs at your gas stations or you're going to be in trouble.
It's not going to be anybody else, but your corporate office and the white only signs came down. But anyway, so we the car followed us. And because I knew of the brick being thrown as the car came up the side of us.
I can't remember. I'm trying to write it for the screenplay now. And I don't really remember if I said anything like look out, rich or whatever. But I started rolling down the window, not that Fred had air conditioning. The windows are probably half done anyway.
Because I didn't want to brick hit the window and shatter. Not that it may have been shattered for a flash. But because I was bunking and sharing a bedroom with Bill and he had been hit by a brick, I was thinking more brick than gun.
Instead what happened the car came up was a pickup truck. Gun came out about this far away. I mean, I'm here. I'm the driver. The passenger car pulls up. The passenger sticks the gun out, bang, bang, bang.
As soon as I saw the gun, I ducked, rich ducked, heard the shots, hit the break and started looking for the bullet holes.
And they took off the guy, the shooters left. And there were no bullet holes, which was very confusing to me because I wasn't far away. To this day, I don't know whether the bullets went through the window or where they were blanks.
Now I've talked to somebody in the military. For whatever reason they said, I don't think it was bullet. I don't think they would have gotten all that trouble with blanks.
On the other hand, it was a good way to scare me and not kill me because it scared me. It scared both of us. Rich I think did leave. I've only talked to him once since then. I've tried to find him. Actually, I haven't been able to find him.
And he said, I thought I was driving. I said no, Rich. I was driving. But he had already been, and they may have been going after him. He may have been, but I had already been to the church.
So he had been already beaten up. I had been to the church. We were both ID'd at that point. See, when we first came down, one of the reasons I got sent to the church for the funeral was they didn't know who we were. But it didn't take long. By that time, both Rich and I were known.
So I don't know who they were following or they were certainly following the car. And to this day, I don't know. The next day I got shot at it again. I heard the bullet hit the bushes, so I know that was a real bullet.
And that was I was just walking with about four black guys. The truck came by. I don't know the same truck or not. I didn't look close enough at the truck the first day. That was all pretty quick first day.
But the second day, I was scared. It was terrifying. I dove in the bushes. The black guys knew instinctively they would be shooting at me. The whites, I didn't know if you've heard this before. The whites hated the white civil rights workers more than they hated the black.
They understood the blacks. They wanted their freedom. Why the hell were the white people helping them? We were race straighters. We were white niggers. We were called white niggers sometimes.
So the black guys knew that if they were shooting at somebody and a lot of black people will tell you this freedom whiteers Bob and Bob, who's used to the freedom whiteers, is white Helen Singleton.
And Bob and Helen Singleton. Helen is on what's his name book, Freedom Writer Book on the cover. I was at Ritt Tuddo's house at a dinner with Helen with Helen with somebody with a journalist. She told him, no, when we were freedom writers, they hated the white some more.
Among moving people that are honest with you, they'll tell you that. And it makes sense. They understood the black people. They didn't like them. They hated them. But they knew why they were doing it. Why were we doing it? We were traders.
And they wanted to make us an example. Without us, the black people, they could kill them without its rebel. So they weren't thinking very clearly because once they killed us, that was even worse. But the black guys laughed at me when I dove in the bushes that second day. They didn't dive in the bushes. I was afraid they were going to come back. I was scared. I was very scared by this. Now I told people, and I think it's really true. The first day really scared me. But it went away. I mean, I was shook up and I told people it's in the incident reports.
And I think the group from Macon didn't want me to stay because they were afraid I was going to get killed. But the second one had a far more lasting effect. If it happens once, they will happen once. Never going to happen again. When it happens, the second time, you don't know when the third time is. And particularly, even to the state, I don't like cars that follow me.
When I drove between making an America, the rest of that summer, no one ever passed me. I knew I had promote supposed dramatic stress. When I got back, I stayed two weeks extra, almost three weeks extra for the election and Macon.
That was my thing for the people in Macon. No, you can't leave. We need you here. Everybody knows number 10. I said, no, it was they want to put me on the staff. They want me to be in America. I'll come back. You see, you're deserting the people in Macon. No, I'll come back. I'll work in the election.
We were our physical project was 10 weeks, June 14th, August 28th. The election was September 15th in Macon. I said, well, gosh, school doesn't start till the 19th. We registered all these voters. We registered over 3000 voters in Macon. Now that our job is to get them to vote, that's the whole point.
Everybody else decided they wanted to leave. They did their time. They did their tour. They were everybody left.
Moral was going to come back, but he left too. Eventually, he did come back. Moral Ruse. I stayed. Anyway, when I got back, and that was when I got the threat from the client the night before that, when I got back, when I was driving down to see Ken Long, I was on the Long Beach Freeway.
The other people also, they drove back. They had time to decompress. From a night 24 hours earlier, they said, if you're still in town, 24 hours are dead. 24 hours later, I landed in LA. I had no decompression time.
Did this threat come from?
The night of the election, oh, you didn't read that in my article. I said, that was in the neighborhood article.
When I stayed for the election in Macon, it was the first black who had run since reconstruction. It was for water commissioners. They said in the article they changed it for commissioners. It was a commissioner, but it was Reverend Marcus Moon. He was a barber and minister.
If you didn't have a full-time church, you needed to support himself. But he stood up. He said, OK, go Randall needed a candidate. He decided to be the candidate.
In the morning of the election, they changed every voting polling place in Macon. At least we knew we had an impact. They put the directions in Boxcore Print. Now many of the black people had not had good educations.
The tiny print was very hard to read. Plus, I think some of them may have been in white neighborhoods. I don't know.
But all of our plans for getting people to the polls were thrown. And of course, the white people that did this knew they were doing that. That's why the Voting Rights Act of 1965 needs to be kept active and approved so that will never happen again.
And I am sympathetic to Alabama and other places that said we haven't had this discrimination in years. The problem is, this is politics. This has nothing to do with race. This could happen. This probably happens in places that I don't know the Voting Rights Act of 1965. If they can get away with it, excuse it, the language for lawyers.
If lawyers run things, they figure a way to get around and manipulate laws. That's what the adversary system, which I don't like, that they've been involved with civil rights law, sets up. If we can get away with it, we do it.
It doesn't matter whether you're interested or guilty, you do what you can get away with. That's part of the adversary system. I understand there's a value to that as well. But that's why the Voting Rights Act of 1965. That's why Scope and Richard "Rick" Tuttle is the one that said this in my book.
Here's what Richard "Rick" Tuttle said, how important Scope was, which is ironic because he's quoted in my book and I give him credit for it. The Voting Rights, some that happened in March, Voting Rights Act of 1965 was stalled till the 6th of August, watched blew up on the 11th.
If the Voting Rights Act of 1965 and all the moral support of the Churches, the White Community Labor Unions was powerful supporting the Voting Rights Act of 1965. If we hadn't got it done by the 6th and the Watts riots or Watts riots had happened, some of that white support through the Churches and the unions would have been weakened.
There was always going to be a Voting Rights Act of 1965. The key question was exactly what's still being debated, the enforcement clause. That's what the Southerners were stalling for and negotiating for no enforcement clause.
Because, of course, without an enforcement clause, the law would have been meaningless, just like the one in 57. That's why Scope was very, very critical to the Voting Rights Act of 1965, both pushing it out of committee. And as history, as Richard "Rick" Tuttle, who's a PhD in history, explained to me, apparently not to you, why Scope was important was because we kept the pressure on and got that vote signed before the first explosion in the North, the worst of the first explosion.
So, but when I was driving on the Long Beach Freeway, whether it's talking about post-traumatic stress, the same lights that bothered me and the South still bothered me and I didn't want them to follow me and I thought, wait a second, that's not right. That's like the guy said, it's not right when the white woman called him or his mother. I said, that's not right. I'm not in Georgia anymore. Those people aren't following me.
But emotionally, I don't want, I don't like, I wanted to get away from them. I didn't want them to pass me. Once that car passed me, I never let another car pass me the rest of the summer and I still don't like cars to pass me.
Because I, I mean, you and I know intellectually and I pretty much know emotionally, that next car ain't going to shoot at me again, but I'm not 100% sure. That's what post-traumatic stress is. Just like these guys who come back from the IUDs, I don't know what they go through because they've had far more, although we have a gun stuck in your face and bullet shot, that's pretty scary.
But I have to watch myself now that when cars are behind me, I have to call myself down and say, what's going on? This is your kicking end, just relax. It's not 1965.
But when I first got back, that was just one of many things I got depressed after that and no one really knew what it was back then. They called it Battle Fatigue and actually I did see the campus psychologist at UCLA.
And they said, well, people from the Peace Corps, they didn't associate it with a danger. What they said, because I don't know if I, I don't know if I verbalized the government or if I understood that part.
But they said people coming back from the Peace Corps from such an intense emotional experience being bonded so closely every day with people in very intense work sometimes had readjustment things.
And that's what they told me at UCLA when I made one attempt to figure out what was going on. It's all a cherry confinement.
That's the second movie. The movie in the South is called The Summer in the South and if that ever gets made, the one in LA would be called a Fall in LA.
112 days. And I tell you, 112 days is not a long, long time in jail, but it's a pretty long time in jail.
How do I ask about that quickly, but I just want to follow up on, because I think the PTSD in movement, Burad, this is a very important thing.
Very important for SNCC. I don't think they understand it. I don't think the SNCC people have ever come to grips. And it's no shame. I mean, it is what it is. It's just your emotional system can only take so much.
And I think they're hostility towards Dr. King, some of the same stuff they feel they haven't enough credit.
They're operating out of those same feelings that they had at the time of all the sacrifices they and their colleagues made. Some of them were shot down right in front of them and nobody was ever, you know, penalized for it.
It's like Jonathan Daniel, the guy who was in jail for eight hours. And that was very important to me too, because that was while I was there and that was not that far away from where I was.
I actually had post-traumatic stress to go to Hainville. I had a real struggle going there to publicize my books for Black Belt Press.
And I talked to Randy one of those one times he helped me. He said, I understand what you're going through, but it'll be good for you to go there.
I said, I know they're not going to shoot me there, but they shot somebody and killed somebody there. I don't want to go there.
I don't want to go there because it makes me afraid because I got shot at it. And you know what happens? I went there first person I saw was a black sheriff. I wasn't afraid anymore.
If you're black people, black people were the good thing. They weren't the ones that were going to shoot me anywhere. It was the white people.
When I was in jail, I had a few, I had some nation of Islam people that didn't care that I worked for Dr. King. I got some stitches in my eye from while fighting in LA County jail. That's a different story though.
It was a white movement related to you. It was. When I was Dr. King's college coordinator, I was over a fair housing thing. Some black kids, Santa Monica had come and heard my music and wanted to hang out. I talked to their mom. I don't think they didn't have a dad.
I was working around my place in Santa Monica in a little court. And then I got a call from, I just moved in. I got a call from the landlord who said, my wife's father just died in Italy. She's upset.
Somebody called and said they were going to bomb my place because you had black people there. This was this fall of 66.
I met a lot of white people in the south. Some very good Betty Adams was a woman from the Methodist Church. We had the first integrated church meeting in Macon because of Betty Adams.
She said, you're working with them. When I was there for those extra three weeks, a number of interesting things happened.
You asked me about the threat. Betty came. One of the good things that happened to Betty said, listen, she found me. She was the first white woman in the postal department. She was her own. She was a feminist before feminism became feminism. A lot of the men didn't like her working in post office because that was a man's job.
She now raises dashhounds in the north of Macon. I've seen her. Her husband put up with all of her integration and stuff. She said, I'm working with the white Methodist youth.
You're working with the black Methodist youth. Why don't we have a meeting at my house? We did. That was the first integrated meeting. Her husband, B.H. Chief Adams, good old southern boy. He let his wife do it.
Because wife runs usually in marriage anyway. That was the first integrated. That was for local white women. There was a guy named Bob Brenner, who I believe is now a lay minister, was going to William & Mary. He reached out to me.
Later, he had a religious house there. That summer, I met him through the church, through the Methodist church. I think he was at that meeting, actually.
What happened with the threat? I was carrying the people down to vote for Marcus Moon. That night after the election, I met Dorandos office with his son Harry, who worked for the state. Harry gets a call and he said, it's for you.
I was calling me at the Burrano's office. Actually, it was at our office. It was at our scope office. I think it was Bill's office to make him a gun.
That's right. I think it was our scope office. I got on the phone and I could tell it was a white voice. It sounded like a nice white man. He said, are you the white man?
I really liked him because I was 18 and he called me a man. I thought this was a compliment. He was going to say something nice to me.
Are you the white man that was carrying the niggas down to vote today? I said yes. Then the voice changed and it wasn't nice anymore.
It said, if you're still here in 24 hours, you did click. It was a very serious, it wasn't saying you're going to be better, be careful.
You're here in 24 hours and you're dead. Click. I told Bill, I said, I'm not leaving. Bill said, oh yes, you're leaving tomorrow morning.
I had already been scheduled to go by Dr. King's office. Everybody else drove back because I stayed and I wasn't in a SCLC field staff.
I had met with Dr. King. I can tell you about that if you want and became a member of the staff. I got a check with Dr. King's signature, which was saved.
It took it to the airport and got my ticket. William P. Randall was already scheduled because I had to get back to school. I had stayed three weeks extra.
I was, you know, the election was over. I was time for me to go home. So I was already scheduled to go. Bill said, no, they're not going to run me out of town. He said, it's time for you to go.
I'm taking you tomorrow morning. I'll be at your house. We're going. We're not discussing this.
Which probably had I sobered up for a second, I would have. I mean, I wasn't, you know, but that was kind of what the movement was.
I mean, I was just making you a point. Whatever. And I had been threatened a lot and I was getting to, I mean, whatever.
So I got on the plane. I fell asleep. I woke up and I'm back in the way. And two nights later, I'm scared driving along me.
You want to hear the Dr. King's story real quick or are you wanting to hear? Do you want me to finish the, I can tell you the real quick story of the Santa Monica.
Dr. King's call. I want to just a little bit about being the coordinator. I know that's because I think it's important to me.
I got to thank Dr. King. I like to tell people about thanking Dr. King because that was very special.
At the end of the summer, they just called me about 40 of us. I think they probably asked probably 60 or 70 of the people they felt did well enough on their work to join the field staff and commit a year to your life.
That was what it was. They came to me. He said, you've done a good job here. We need to get a lot more work to do. I want to keep scope going.
I want you to commit a year to your life. Stay down with us. And I said, you know, and I want you to come on staff now. So I went on staff in America.
And I said, you know, I knew my dad didn't like it too much. I didn't have parental prayers. But I was also getting a little worn out.
But I also knew that I'd be classified 1A. I'd lose my student deferment. So I wasn't going to be, I don't know how I was able to, I don't know how I was able to, I was able to figure that out.
And I don't know, maybe some other women didn't have that problem. And some did stay. The guys that did, I don't know how they worked that out. Maybe they had to deferment, you know, pass the deferment, whatever.
But I didn't have a deferment. So I said, but I'll stay two weeks. I'll stay for the election to make it. So that was fine.
So the day the project officially ended, which was August 28th, which is actually the anniversary of the I have a dream speech, that was the official date of the conclusion.
We got called to that day was, those days it was West Hunter Street Baptist Church, which was Reverend Abernathy's Church. Now West Hunter Street is Martin Luther King Drive in Atlanta.
So we were in the basement. And Dr. King came and Gwen Green who ran the WCLC was there and she was given flowers. Ben Clark was there, Hosea Williams was there and Dr. King was there.
And he we were told that because we were now on staff, Dr. King wanted to talk to us. So he came out and he gave this wonderful speech. And Hosea Williams had all the data of how many registered voters 49,302, I think it was kept records of everything, which is in my book.
And went over all of our accomplishments in the idea of the idea. Then he said, I've come out against the war. And I want you to understand it's very controversial.
You're now representing our organization representing me. I want you to be able to explain to people who may ask you why I've done what I've done. Now, Dr. King came out twice against the war. He came out in 65. He actually had to retrench because there was so much criticism.
And his own board was against it. He then kind of kept quiet and Coretta Scott King went around to anti-war marches and did anti-war concerts. And she was the spokesperson against the Vietnam War.
He then two years later, actually the anniversary of his death, April 4, 1967 at the Riverside Church in New York, made his statement against the war.
But he didn't know that he was going to have to retract at that point. At that point, he was out front. He was also up in Chicago much of that summer.
So he thanked us. He explained it. And he said, are there any questions? And people have often said, you know, he also spoke to us. You know, I heard him at UCLA. I heard him at the orientation. But this was in a small group.
And there were some people there. And we're in line. I got to spend a lot of time with him. I did not get to spend a lot of time with Hosea Williams.
Sometime with Andy, although not that summer, really. When Andy came out to LA and Hosea Williams would come out to LA. Not never saw Dr. King in LA, but I saw Andy in Hosea Williams.
So sometimes I was not in town, whatever. I was organizing him in Northern California.
But so he said, are there any questions? And you know, you got 20 teenagers or a little older kind of awestruck because Martin Luther King has been thanking them.
And me, you know, I worked out with Brooklyn Dodgers. I was with my heroes many time. And he was one of my heroes, but I was not awestruck enough.
And I've often said, he wasn't the Martin Luther King orator. He was like Martin Luther King, the youth minister, the YMCA coordinator, just very soft spoken.
Knowing I felt very strongly, I feel this now, he knew we were an awe of him. He went out of his way and knew how to make people feel comfortable. And he knew he was famous. It wasn't a big thing to him.
I mean, that was just part of his job. And he made you feel comfortable. And he just seemed like this nice guy, just like he had seen me at UCLA, which I said in a program with Hosea Williams.
Everybody else, because Hosea Williams was worrying, what am I going to say? We were all supposed to give memories of Dr. King on his show, The Voice of the Crusader. And he knew I didn't know Dr. King.
Everybody else did. We're all the SEO veteran. And I just said, I didn't try and wing it. I mean, I don't do that. I didn't try. Well, Dr. King, I got to know him.
I said, he just was a nice guy. I said, I only heard him that one time close up. And I heard me say, he seemed like he was a nice guy. Everybody else, yeah, Dr. King was really a nice guy.
Because he said, you know, you think of Dr. King as a famous person. He was a person. And he took him three hours to walk from Ebenezer Baptist Church home, because he would walk home and talk to everybody along the way.
Because he was a nice guy too. Tonight, he just wanted to be a nice guy. So, and Coretta Scott King was a extraordinarily nice person. I'm very fortunate to did get to know her and work with her.
I'd write a letter to my father when he was ill, which was very meaningful to my father. After all, I'd been through in jail and stress. And I'm sure the stress of my being in jail when I was 19 and 20.
Not good for my mom. She died a little more than a year later. That's why I went to Taylor Branch, use of the FBI documents. And I was in jail.
The police chief was Peter J. Pitchess, who had been an FBI agent. And the FBI knew who I was and Marcus Crane, who said, Sirhan Sirhan was sane after he killed Robert F. Kennedy and said, I needed to be locked up in a mental hospital.
Because I worked for Martin Luther King. It's extremely personal. The Taylor Branch has exploited that FBI terrible period, which the FBI has acknowledged was a terrible period. And the Congress acknowledges he had made money out of the pain that was caused by the FBI.
It's very personal to Taylor. And Taylor knows that. Taylor is a coward. I've tried to talk to Taylor about it. I tried to help Taylor. And he trashed scope. And then he put it head to the nerve to put my name. And his notes saying that I helped him with his book.
I helped him when he was in Selma, not knowing how to find Martin Luther King III. Because he wanted to march in the reenactment in 2005, which he had the nerve to say was risking something.
It was a joke. It was protected. He said, Oh, that was dangerous to march. Taylor is great at insinuating. But I had an argument with Harris Waffer. He says, you should get off of Taylor Branch. He doesn't like Taylor. He's letting me quote him saying Taylor Branch used too much to the FBI.
He didn't do much without explaining the things. I told Harris just recently. We had a argument about it because Taylor didn't put Harris's criticized Taylor Branch publicly. And he didn't put Harris's name in his new book, although he mentioned the phone call from Kennedy and Coretta Scott King, which Harris set up.
And he said, America and the King years and you leave out Dr. King's friend who set up the phone call. And he said he did it for brevity. He says in a part, this is original part that he wrote for this new book. And he cut Harris's name out.
And he Harris thought I was being too critical. I don't think I think it was done intentionally because Harris Taylor Branch thinks that he's so important. And he's so egotistical that he gets to decide who's in the movement. And if he doesn't put you in, you're not in.
Scopes not in there either. Just like scope wasn't in eyes on the prize. Just like some of the snake people don't want to mention scope anymore. Despite the fact that many snake people worked with scope.
His names are in my book in our records because they were arrested with us. And the families that hosted up, of course, were African American.
So it's, and that's why Sammy Mahone has been such a great, so great to have brought Willie Bowen that in me and John R. Lewis and Willie Ricks, who said the black power thing who told me to leave Americus Willie Willie was there said white boy, we don't want you here.
We want you to only value is to raise money in the North. And that was after Stokely Carmichael. It said two months earlier, we're going to sabotage scope.
And some of those people are still following Stokely Carmichael's admonition from the meeting in Holly Springs, Mississippi in May of 1965, which is in their minutes, which then Ralph Featherstone, who I got to know in Berkeley at a teaching 67 who got blown up in a car in Maryland.
I'm sure he didn't blow himself up, I think those explosives were planted by the government. Ralph said, let's go off record these files are in the King Center and the snake papers.
He says, what do you mean sabotage Dr. King and scope? And they went off record and Ralph was against it. Stokely Carmichael said it. That's Titter branches marches orders.
And Stokely Carmichael himself or Stokely Carmichael himself when he had cancer in late in his life with with Lewis Farrakhan, Louis Farrakhan in Washington.
It's on video. I've not seen it, but I've heard of it. Louis Farrakhan started making negative comments about Dr. King.
And when Stokely Carmichael was was in his last months of life, he said, do not say anything bad about Dr. King.
He said, we attack Dr. King many, many times. This is on a video. I don't know where it is. It was filmed when they had a fundraiser for Stokely Carmichael and Washington in Louis Farrakhan was there.
That's what I've been told. And he said, Dr. we attack Dr. King all those times, he never attacked us back.
It finally Stokely Carmichael got the message. Willie Rick saw me at the 2007. I was late to a thing at the little tiny armory they have there at dance.
And there's been many times I was the only white person there for the last couple hours. Willie noticed me. I went back and I were dancing different ones and having a good time because I was late getting there.
I was outside with Willie. I had seen Willie over the years. Willie spoke at Hosea Williams's memorial service. And Terry Randolph was very close with Hosea Williams. And Willie came up to me and he said, I'm Willie Rick. I'm friends with Terry Randolph.
I was friends with him. He worked with Hosea Williams. I said, I know Willie. We were down here together in 65. I said, I know who you are. I know. I know you.
And I was thinking to you, Willie, it took you only took 40 years for you to want to be friends. Like 45 years. I'm glad we can be friends now.
Because he told me in 65, he said, I hate all white people. He said a black state trooper in Alabama beat me up. And I hate all white people. And I said, you know, I'm really sorry that happened with a black three trooper.
There's nothing to do with me. That community here is asked us here. Dr. King asked us here. Hosea Williams asked us here. And then I went in with another guy, a young guy in Dr. King staff.
And we're working off stress due in 50 sit-ups at a time. And Willie watched us do in the 50 sit-ups. And then he didn't say anything else to me.
But he tried to intimidate me. And you know, I mean, Willie, these white people have been shooting at me. You really can have kind of a hard time intimidating me.
And there was another black guy at a meeting who told me to shut up that I didn't have a right to speak. And I said, no, I have a right to speak. I'm out in the front line.
And it was usually the guy who's one in the front line to tell the white people they shouldn't be there.
And you know, Willie was the guy in the flatbed truck with Hosea Williams. Willie was yelling black power on the Meredith March. And Hosea Williams was yelling freedom now.
And I don't dislike, well, I'm glad Willie and I can be friends. And I'm glad that just like when Malcolm X made the pilgrimage to Mecca,
and he saw that there were all different shades of Islam that he came back and it was a changed man. And was moving towards Dr. King,
which Jackie Robinson writes about in his autobiography because he knew Malcolm X. And Malcolm had criticized him and was reconciling with him.
And I just think that I give all the credit in the world for the snake people, for their valor and their courage. And they're in my book. Their pictures are in my book.
Equally to SCLC from the King Center, the young snake group, young SCLC group. Stokely Carmichael is in there. Eldridge Cleaver is in there.
That's the true history. But you know what? The true history includes the 500 of us who went south, lived with black families, as Nick wanted us to do.
We said, live in the community. Don't come in and out. That was their criticism of Dr. King. So we did just what they wanted, what they did.
We made roots. And some of those Nick scope organizations in a number of communities are still in existence as multimillion dollar community organizations that started during scope.
And that process was something that we registered 49,203 voters, many before the Voting Rights Act of 1965. And we stood on their shoulders.
They were the foundation that we followed. And that instead of resenting us, we're the same. We're together. We're part of them. And some of them are now within these books that are coming out based partly from the reunion organized.
They're now embracing us. Maria Giddens book in particular about Camden, Alabama, in that county. She interviewed 26 families, many of whom were Nick, because many of the people that had been with Nick hosted the scope families and the scope volunteers.
And that's what I always said. When you cut us out, you cut the families out that we lived with and the people that we marched with.
And it was done out of the feeling that Dr. King got all the publicity and they didn't get their fair share. They got plenty of publicity. But I think it was more based on post-traumatic stress.
Post-traumatic stress and depression is experienced in many, many, many different variations. I experienced it in my way. Believe me, anybody who went through what many of the people in the world and the freedom writers went through.
Another criticism was that Dr. King didn't get on the bus in Montgomery and go the rest of the way on a freedom ride. Dr. King had three children or two children at that time. And a wife, these were single people. I was single.
Easier for us to put our lives on the line. We don't have children. We don't have wives. And they criticize them for that. You know what? Time to get over it.
It's history. I make no criticism for anything that was done at that time because when people have their lives on the line that are years of stress, people used to go to Atlanta for R&R and they self-medicated, they would go out and drink.
It's what soldiers do. That's what soldiers do because of the fear of the stress. That's okay. That's why I wanted to tell Frank Smith Jr in Washington when he told me, we were first words out of us. We weren't tougher than Dr. King. When I told him about the son of the bitch thing.
No, you were as tough. You didn't have a bulls eye on you every day that Dr. King had every day until one day he got him. He knew that. He knew that.
He'd Harris-Waffer talks about that. That his wife, Coretta Scott King, talked about that in 56. And he went out every day without any protection. That's pretty good. That's pretty amazing. He deserved, he was the leader.
That doesn't mean that Frank Smith Jr wasn't the leader, that Kwame Ture and Stokeley were leaders too. They were great leaders. He was the main leader. He had it all. He had the education, he had the oratory, he had the courage, he had the humanity.
He was an African American. He was proud of him. He was part of you. You were part of him. In the same old scope.
The people I don't like are the David Garros and the Taylor branches. Taylor was not involved. He claimed he sat in a jail so he was arrested. He never went behind bars.
He wanted to be like, I heard him on the radio. He wanted to be Stokely Carmichael Carmichael so I got a black card game. Then he got picked up by the sheriff. He didn't want him to get in trouble. Then he sat in the jail and he showed his yellow ID.
He went off to his motel. 1969. Not part of the era. But he was trying to build his resume. That's what the guy is about. I'm telling you this because I know the guy. I dealt with him enough so I don't talk about it. He said this to his face. I said it in Birmingham at a meeting when he was at the Civil Rights Institute.
I don't talk about people. Some people didn't like it. I said it there. Harris has also said it much nicer than me. I'm about using the FBI stuff.
Anyway, if you want to ask a question about being the college coordinator, I can give that real quick. I would like to talk about the 21st of the 21st.
I appreciate that. I appreciate that. Unfortunately, this history of scope has been left out. The reason is why I think it's worth talking about.
Sammy Mahone is the model. He was a snake leader in America. He's a leader. He's had us both there. He did it before I said it. I'm following Sammy's lead. He's embracing everybody and being inclusive.
It's time we do that. That's the true story. That involves more black people than white people. Taylor is right about that. It was a tiny number of Jews, a tiny number of others.
Percentage-wise, we are a tiny group. The whites. Even in the black community, although it's a pretty significant part of the black community was involved one way or another. Not everybody. Not everybody.
Even then, you were taking big risks. You want to ask questions about being the college coordinator.
Maybe just one last thing that you want to say.
The college coordinator was, I got back. I walked into the meeting and Gwen Green, who was a leader, said,
because I came back late because I had been in the South. I went to the first meeting. I got there late. She said,
our leader is here. Our coordinator is here. I literally looked behind me to see what she was talking about.
I think what happened was when I raised my hand and talked to Dr. King. Hannah was there and talked it over. They decided that I would be the college coordinator.
I protested that I was the youngest one. Gwen said, no, you've been selected. I later asked her many years, why did I get to see her? We knew you would do a good job. We saw you did good work.
I organized a conference. The real thing was, the scope was kind of ending. Black Power was starting. Hannah War Movement was starting. It was very hard to recruit.
Dr. King only had one reach, two regional offices. One in DC was a lobbying office at Rev. Walter Fauntroy, Rand. One was the Western Christian Leadership Conference,
Southerner Christian Leadership Conference, Rev. Thomas Kilgore Jr, who had been in New York, was now out here. He was the president.
These ministers around the country that Dr. King had organized back in 57 as the SCLC. Some at least Kilgore had come from, Reverend Kilgore had come from New York out here.
I don't know where he was in 57, but he had been a long-term guy. We did the conference. We did Operation Breadbasket, where we went when Jesse Jackson was starting in Chicago.
We started there, apparently. I was not quite as charismatic as Jesse. He had more SCLC troops there. We did evaluations and we got jobs.
We did exactly the same thing. Went around to the stores in the black areas. How many employees do you have?
Worked with the churches. That was a WACLC scope, SCLC kind of thing out here. But when Andy and Hosea Williams would come out periodically,
when would call me down there at 2401 Southwestern Avenue. I think, two, I think it is, it's in the book.
That's what we get that address right.
2400, 2400 Southwestern Avenue, Suite 102, Los Angeles, California, I know 018. It was Thomas Kilgore, was the director Western Bureau SCLC, which was essentially W.
Then we had Marvin T. Robert, Marvin T. Robert, Marvin T. Robert, Marvin T. Robert, the president of W.C.L.C.
Robert, Marvin Stovall, chairman of the board W. So they had their own board. It was Western Christian leaders from Congress, Mountain Earth, the King, Jr. Founder.
It was sort of a separate board. It was Washington, Oregon, California, Nevada, Arizona, Colorado, and Mexico, Utah, Alaska, and Hawaii.
When Green was the director of the director, she since told me that all the male ministers didn't make it that she had to fight as a woman.
But she was the executive director. She was a woman in the leadership. She was on the payroll. I think she was probably the only one on the payroll.
She had a labor background. She later worked for Councilman Bob Farrell, still alive, still in LA.
That's a great history for that neighborhood. I hope someday we're going to get a marker there. Let those schools in that area know that the ministers in that area know that they're part of the Martin Luther King legacy directly.
Dr. King went to that when he spoke of the sports arena, not long before he died, I'm sure he was at W.C.L.C.
And then so I did a number of things. I organized a little bit up in Berkeley. I had James Bevel come out. I had this incident where the kids in my neighborhood, these three black kids came over. They were like 10, 8, and 6.
I talked to their mom as it okay if they visit. A landlord said, you know, I want you to move. I said it's against the law to make a threat.
But I had told all these white people I talked about Betty Adam. But the main thing, the white people that didn't want to shoot me came up and particularly in making, not in America. They didn't talk to you in America.
They shot at you. But in making, they would talk to me. They'd say, you're a hypocrite. What have you done? Isn't there any problems back in LA?
And of course, once the Watts situation happened when I was at a coin in the air at the time, I thought, these white people here might have a point.
We might have some problems in California. And that was another reason why I told Hosea Williams I can't stay. I've got work to do where I live. And that's so I ended up doing work here.
And so, you know, so that stuff was going on. And I organized a little bit up in Northern California.
You know, the organization was a big organization. I didn't do anything. I was essentially the Western States college coordinator. But I was only doing things in Northern Southern California.
And then, but because, so I would know Andy and Hosea Williams, that was a key thing. The other thing was because of being on the staff, when Dr. King made his appeal about Resurrection City three years later, he didn't appeal that he wrote for look magazine before he died.
That came out after he died April 4th that said we need volunteers to go to demonstrate. We've had all these summers of violence in the in the black sections around the country.
We need to channel this into a non violent way in Washington at the poor people's campaign. And I felt that was worth me going. My dad was very against it. I had been in jail. I dropped out of school. I just gotten back in school.
And he didn't want me to go. In fact, he told me if you go this time, I'm cutting you off. Well, he hadn't given me any money since when I was out of school. And he hadn't given me any, give me $100 for the, my dad thought it was like when the tuition wasn't the 50s.
So, I, you know, and he was pretty serious. And I understood why my mom at that point was ill. They were divorced, but she was, you know, she died that fall. It was a lot of stress for my family. It's another reason why I resent people who weren't there like Taylor Branch or David Garrow cutting out those of us.
It wasn't just me who's my family shared that experience. It was hard on them. My family never ever, many of my cousins don't understand, they haven't understood it. The post-traumatic stress I had, they haven't understood. They never even asked me what happened. The Jewish community has never asked me until it had been a breath last year.
You know, this is a big deal in my life and a big deal in my family's life. I never worried about it not being written about, but when Taylor Branch and David Garrow went out of their way to trash us and disrespect our work and falsify our work with fake documents. That was a little too much for me.
For somebody like Taylor Branch is my age who was having a comfortable summer in Atlanta when I was down getting shot at.
Walk the walk if you want to talk about that. Willie Ricks, Rick's Walk the Walk. I'll discuss that with them without a problem. I don't hold it against them. I think we need to bond and be a team together as we were in many places anyway.
Anyway, with these kids, they were there, turned out the landlord was an ex-sendom on a policeman, which I didn't know at the time. When I went down there, they said, we're not going to do anything. I said, I need somebody to come and take a report.
So we're not going to take a report. Because the landlord told them I wasn't telling the truth and he was an ex-cop. I was really worried because I told you, when I came out, I said, I'm not putting up with this anymore.
I really didn't know. I went and saw my rabbi who had paid my way for me and four other Jewish students from UCLA. He said, guns are okay. He knew about Israel of independence or whatever. He said, if you need protection at your house, you need protection at your house.
The first thing you need to do is find out whether there was really a threat. You better call the landlord and see if he's telling the truth.
Well, that was a discussion after Friday night services by a time the cold landlord was maybe 930-10 at night on a Friday night.
And I had bought a gun. The police told me, if you want any protection by a gun, that's when I asked the rabbi. And I bought a gun. I said, can I have a gun? They said, you can have a shotgun if you're over 18.
I went down and bought a shotgun. I mean, I'd been through again. This was the real deal to me. I mean, I'd been through it. I wasn't about to have that happen again.
Not Dr. King would have been happy about it. I'm not sure that Hosea Williams would have cared. So I had the shotgun. I didn't want anything happen.
I talked to the rabbi, I called the landlord and I said, look, please told me to buy. I didn't know he was next cop at the time. I'll find that out later.
So I didn't know, I said, I don't know, I want to know if this is true. I've talked to my rabbi. The police told me to buy a gun. I'm worried somebody might bomb my place.
That's what you told me. Is that true? Were you making that up? Or was it true? He hung up at me, called the police, told him that I was threatening people with a shotgun. That's not a good thing.
They came down with a city attorney named Herbert Lapine. I'd love to get his name in because he told my dad he was going to put me in jail for life.
I had a gun, because I had the gun with me. I didn't have a phone yet. I went down to the corner at Santa Monica in 26th Street. Call from a phone booth.
I was walking back. I had had taken self-defense from a guy named Brick's Hunt. He was the wrestling coach and an Olympic wrestling coach and a drill instructor from World War II.
Once I knew I was going to go, I took self-defense and I paid attention when they taught about guns. I had the gun open, but it was loaded.
I was walking back. I came in my alley and there were two policemen from Santa Monica with guns up. They said, drop the gun. I said it's broken open. I can't be fired. Herbert Lapine, the city attorney, was there.
They said, you have three. Drop the gun. I said, it can't be dropped. They said, two. I dropped the gun. They would have killed me. Just like you read about all the black panthers I got, I would have become almost a sympathetic black panther in a sense that I wasn't going to take it anymore.
Deacon defense, that's where I was. Not a good place to be. That's where I was. Drop the gun. They took it. I said, okay, you're here now. Will you take the report about the bomb threat?
No, we don't think you're stable enough for the gun. We're taking the gun. I at that point wasn't experiencing post-traumatic stress, but I had had a depression. By that point I was feeling fine. I was in really good shape. I had built fences for my alcohol all summer. I was in great shape.
They took the gun. They wouldn't take a report. I went back down there, followed him down on my motorcycle. Not again a good idea. I was 19. I said, I want you to take the report. They said, get the hell out of here. We're going to beat the shit out here. Put you in jail. Get out here. This was before Tom Hayden and Jane Fonda socialized Santa Monica. It was a different town back then.
This is fall 66. One back home, two days later, it had been three days. I called from a phone booth. I said, look at it. It's three days. I'm calm down. I told myself, I still keep taking it. I want a property receipt. It wouldn't even give me a property receipt.
Essentially, they stole my gun. I couldn't be a very good black Panther without my gun. I'm joking about the black. I didn't use that terminology.
I was doing what later people did when they got frustrated with injustice and brutality. I was at the same phone booth and they said, okay, we'll bring where are you? I told them I had the phone booth. We'll bring it down to you.
The cop car comes down. The guy jumped out and I'm in the thing. I said, oh, you brought my gun. They said, no, you're under arrest. Again, in the phone booth. I can just out. It's what Bob Zellner calls up north. I said, what a matter of arrest for? They said, you're disturbing the piece. I said, you're not going to make that sick. I'm in the phone booth.
They said, I'll make it sick. The guy grabbed me and twisted my arm and started pulling me to the car. I said, take your fucking hands off me. I said, you can arrest me but don't touch me.
So then he came at me and I went in the car. That's when I told him, we're going to the station. I said, when you got on this car, I said, don't touch me. I said, you can put me in jail. Do not touch me.
He said, if I have to use my ability, he said, I'm going to do what I have to do. If I have to hit you, I said, do you have to use your ability?
I have to use my fucking. This was what was going on in my mind. We got out of the car right behind the book in the parking room. The parking station is still there right off the freeway.
He came at me and I, like I said, was a very good shape. I had self defense. I knocked him down and jumped on him. I did learn and the jail psychiatrist later told me, that is not a good thing to do. He hit a policeman outside a booking room at a police station.
I was on top of him and then four police, they came out of the station pretty quickly when they hear that's going on, when their officers is down.
And four officers, each grab, each one grab legs and arms and pulled me off, threw me over and bang my head on the ground until I passed out.
I told them, once they had me spread eagle, I was stopping. I said, okay, they kept smashing my head on the ground until I passed them.
They broke me in and they punched me around. Then they said, I said, okay, you got me here? You got me for disturbing the piece? I'm going to sue you.
Another nut could really sell him that later. They said, well, you know what? You promised to move out of town and let you go.
That's when I should have said, yes. Again, 19 years old, I said, no, I'm going to sue you. I said, I'm a civil rights worker, I'm going to sue you.
They put me in jail and they charged me instead of disturbing the piece, they charged me with a 653 MAPC of the penal code.
I'm not sure that it exists anymore. It's a threatening or obscene phone call. They said that I threatened them over the phone, that I threatened the police department over the phone.
Nobody can prove what anybody says unless they have an untamed. They never thought I was ever going to have to go to trial and they dropped charges from that chain.
They put what they call a department 95, which is a psychiatric hold, which is then a pathway to institutionalization commitment. That's what they tried to do.
What happened was they sent me to a guy named Ronald Markman, who still alive became a very famous jail psychiatrist and wrote in a book, a UCLA in his own Westwood.
He saw me and he was a cool guy. He was in his 30s at the time and he said, what are you doing here? You're a UCLA student. I said, well, this is what happened. He said, okay.
He said, you're not crazy. I'm going to give you a clearance. My parents couldn't bail me out. We got a department 95. You can't even get bail. My parents are going to bail me out. They couldn't get me out.
He said, I'm going to get bailed out. I said, I'm telling you two things. I said, you're probably going to want to protest the Vietnam or I'm going to tell you never hit a cop and particularly never at a booking room.
He said, okay, you're okay. I got bailed out and I couldn't live in the place. I went to stay with my girlfriend and something happened with her and my ex roommate, Guy, from the club, UCLA came by.
I got an argument with him. He called the police. He told them that I was out on bail on the other. They arrested me for battery, which was bogus, but the two city attorneys got together.
They then held me in jail 112 days. I called Hosea Williams. I tried to get to Atlanta. I got kicked off the Delta airline plane. Hosea Williams said, come down here. We can't do anything for you there. I said, the media won't take the story. Come down here and I actually got kicked off the plane. They sent me back.
They told me I worked for Martin Luther King. Not the same Delta Airlines either. I told the students, I worked for Martin Luther King and they kicked me off the plane.
I just likened the Jackie Robinson movie. They kicked me off the plane. They happened to me. I have a little intersection with the Jackie Robinson.
Anyway, make the long story short. Immediately when they found out my mother was a professor at USC. My father was a prominent chiropractor. He was the national public relations chair for the National Care Chiropractic Association.
I've been on the Today Show. It was very prominent at that time. They offered me a deal. We'll drop charge. You signed a stipulation of probable cause. You can't sue us. We'll drop the threatening phone call charge.
I wouldn't do it, which pissed my dad off. Then they brought me to trial to the other one. The city attorney came down and lied to me and said, witnesses were going to be there that weren't there.
I got convicted by a judge. A guy named Woodman Z was a liberal judge of Mr. Meanor Battery and Distoring the Peace. They then put me up for another department 95.
In the jail at that time, they had one chief jail psychiatrist. That was Marcus Crane. He was a colleague of Peter J. Pitchess. He was a colleague of J. Edgar Hoover.
Marcus Crane wrote a terrible report. They told me about me. The same guy that two years later said Sirhan was not sick for killing. He was completely sane when he killed Bobby Kennedy.
I thought that was interesting. I was sick for having attacked a policeman who had defended myself against a policeman, but Sirhan was not sick for killing.
Finally, I kept or went back to Markman. He said, what are you doing here again? I said, well, I got arrested again. They messing with me.
I'm going to certify you again, but he said, you got to start being careful here. You're getting arrested too much. Then they took me to court and they said, we want to send him back again.
They wouldn't try me on the second charge. On the first charge. They sent me to all the jail psychiatrists. They had ten of them.
When I got to the eighth one, he told me, they had to have two. They had to have Crane, the head guy and one other one, then they could put me up for commitment. They would never have to try me for the criminal charge.
They started telling me, the last couple of psychiatrists, they told me, they said, we know Dr. Markman. We've seen this report. They talked to me. They said, you're not crazy. They said, but you better be careful. They are trying to put you away and throw away the key.
You are in trouble now. You've got to start being more careful and take this more seriously and not get arrested again when you get out.
Finally, they could never get the second guy. They finally had, and they kept taking continuances on the threatening phone call.
When I went to court after the third continuance, Herbert Lapine said to my dad, I'm going to put him away for life. That's when my dad said over my dead body.
He was trying to pique a chiropractor and lead her in his field. He had been a long struggle after World War II out of the projects. He was just remarried doing well. Here's his son in all this stuff.
Finally, I go back to court on the sentencing for the battery and they say, we're going to let you out, but you have to be committed.
I said, I'm not going to be committed. I just went to your psychiatrist and eight out of nine or nine out of ten. They sent me to ten. Nine out of ten said, they don't need to be committed. Why would I want to commit myself?
Then Judge Woodman said, okay, six months in jail. I had already been in two months back to jail. But at that time, I didn't cause any trouble in jail. Before I flooded the jail, I had stopped a black Muslim nation of Islam guy beating up a Hispanic guy, which he then later put him in the same cell block.
He hit me with a bar soap with a razor blade and cut my eye. I tried to actually was trying to kill me. He kicked me in the head with his boots. The funny part of that was there was quite a bit of blood. And when they took me in to sew me up, some of the deputies came in.
Then kind of liked me because they thought it was kind of tough. And I wasn't causing too many more problems because I had decided I would go back to jail instead of going to a mental hospital.
So they said, love and thought we knew somebody was going to get you. And I think he was put up to it by then. And I said, well, they said, we knew somebody's going to get you. I said, well, they said, yeah, I busted open your eye. I said, well, I know I got a few on him. And they said, he was this guy with his name was Hugo Maxi. He was on parole, from from solid. He was a tough guy.
When I got down he kicked me I threw him over me, which I learned from Big Sun. Got up and kicked me in the head with big boots. And that's when I realized this is not a regular fight. This guy is trying to kill me.
So I got up and I defended myself. How's on my feet when it ended? So they said, I said, well, I know I got a few on with him. Didn't he have some injuries? And they said, the only thing we noticed with Hugo Maxi, some of his knuckles were bruised. That seemed to be the only damage he did with him.
So what happened was to finish it out. I go back to court. So then they hear that, so I finally got to go back to court on the original charge of disturbing the piece. This is now three and a half months later or two hundred and twelve days later.
And they have no more psychiatrist to send me to. They've run out. They can't do the department 95. So they make a deal with the judge with men's Z.
And the day before I'm supposed to go back to Santa Monica or that week, they bring you back to West LA and they say, we're going to commute your six months to time serve.
But we just want you to have outpatient counseling. And my parents are that my dad tells me to take this. And I was at that point, I realized I wasn't going to have publicity and it wasn't going to change things.
Wasn't going to clean up the LAPD, which we know have had a few problems since then. I needed to get cleaned up and the corruption within this DA's.
So I took that deal. They let me out of jail. Then I went back and they were still offering me the stipulation of probable cause and dropped the charges on the Santa Monica one. And my dad told me, sign the document.
I want to be done with this. And I signed it, which made me very depressed. And I've never forgotten that experience in our justice system. And that's why I have great sympathy for those, for example, in SNCC or the Black Panthers who felt that the system
and I'm a middle class white guy, upper middle class parent dad, the doctor, mom, the USE professor at this point. If they can do that to me, think what they can do to a poor black person and what they still do, we have an argument. This is the final thing I'll say we have something called stipulation.
We have they've changed from stipulation of probable cause, which you have to sign to something you have no choice to sign, which is called arguable probable cause and qualified immunity.
And that is why the innocent project is having to free and is so overloaded with so many people incarcerated because of the same prosecutor like Herbert Lapine who wanted me to sign something.
They later became judges and they put in a thing about 20 years ago, which Alan Dershowitz has written about in others, that it's called arguable probable cause and qualified immunity, which means a government can put you in jail.
And you can't sue them because they don't have complete immunity, but they call it qualified immunity, but all they need to trigger qualified immunity is arguable probable cause and anything is arguable.
I had a civil rights case in Iowa, which I'm not going to go into details of where a judge found unadisturbing the piece charge or disorderly conduct similar to the one that the guy at Harvard, the scholar, he didn't sue. I did sue.
They dropped the charges, but I sued them because I'm a civil right and not a civil rights educator, a Harvard professor. I'm a real civil rights worker, unlike I forget his name. He never was a civil rights worker, but he's a famous civil rights scholar. That's the difference between the scholars and the workers we follow through.
He never sued them, the boss, the Cambridge police. I sued the state patrol in Iowa. The judge found my fourth amendment right was violated. There was no probable cause. He found the state trooper who was 6 foot 640 pounds and I believe anti-Semitic was out at the Des Moines Register bike ride, which I'd done 20 times.
I was trying to stop some drunks from harassing me and other people and he believed the drunks who weren't Jewish, but targeted me. I did mention that I was a civil rights worker to him. He also found the guy's story incredible, but arguable. He let him off.
That's the next civil rights thing. I appealed to the Supreme Court. They went here in the case. That's why so many innocent people are going to court and that qualified immunity needs to be changed. That's my current civil, and that's what the Innocence Project is about. They were supporting me informally on what I do.
My little story. This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.